bien mesdames la ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques messieurs les rapporteurs
mais chers collègues nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui pour échanger sur
le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production des
énergies renouvelables
présentées en conseil des ministres et
déposer sur le bureau du Sénat le lundi
26 septembre et qui sera examiné en
commission le 26 octobre prochain et en
séance publique dès le 3 novembre
l'équilibre général du texte à justifier
un renvoi du projet
de loi à la commission d'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
la commission des affaires économiques
est également largement concernée par le
texte cette des 20 articles du projet de
loi lui ont d'ailleurs été délégué au
fond par notre commission
cet examen conjoint justifie cette
audition elle est aussi commune de la
mini chargée de porter ce texte Madame
Agnès que je remercie pour sa présence
en guise d'introduction avant de laisser
la parole à ma collègue présidente
Sophie prima j'aimerais rappeler que ce
projet de loi s'inscrit dans un contexte
énergétique particulièrement difficile
qui doit nous pousser à trouver des
solutions pour assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de notre pays
cela implique une relocalisation de
notre production d'énergie en substitant
les sources fossiles par des sources
décarbonées souveraineté énergétique et
ambition climatiques se rejoignent donc
plus que jamais je rappelle que pour
atteindre notre objectif de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
France devra se substituer rapidement et
substituer rapidement sa consommation
d'énergie fossiles par de l'électricité
du gaz ou de la chaleur des carbonées
tout en réduisant très largement sa
consommation énergétique dans ce
contexte selon RTE un fort développement
de l'ensemble des énergies renouvelables
électriques sera indispensable quel que
soit le scénario retenu même dans le
scénario de neutralité carbone le plus
ambitieux en matière de nucléaire le
développement du gaz et de la chaleur
renouvelable devront également être
accélérés pour répondre aux besoins des
secteurs qui ne pourront pas bénéficier
de l'électrification des usages
malheureusement la France fait
aujourd'hui figure de mauvais élèves
dans le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables ce retard dans un contexte
où le parc nucléaire historique se
trouve en souffrance nous est
préjudiciables il met en danger notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement et nous
pousse à réouvrir des centrales à
charbon au regard de ces éléments le
projet de loi qui nous est proposé
est-il à la hauteur de l'enjeu on peut
sérieusement en douter à la lecture du
texte on peine tout d'abord apercevoir
les gains de temps réellement permis
dans l'instruction des dossiers et le
développement des projets de plus même
en simplifiant les procédures en
supposant que les porteurs de projets
disposent des capacités industrielles
pour développer rapidement les
installations les effets des services
déconcentrés de l'État devront être
nécessairement renforcé pour traiter
tous les dossiers peut-être madame la
ministre pouvez-vous nous aider à lever
nos doutes sur ces sujets
par ailleurs les pineuses problématique
de l'approbation locale des énergies
renouvelables et survolée par le projet
de loi la proposition formulée par
l'article 18 du texte un rabais sur la
facture d'électricité des Riva semble un
peu courte pour répondre à un problème
qui s'avère profond
acceptabilité et accélération doivent
aller de pair car sans acceptabilité
locale les contentieux continueront de
fleurir et les projets peineront à
sortir de terre j'attendons là aussi
madame la ministre des réponses
avant de vous laisser la parole je la
cède à ma collègue Sophie prima
président de la commission des affaires
économiques merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre chers Président mes
chers collègues des deux commissions à
mon tour je vous remercie madame la
ministre de votre présence parmi nous
pour nous éclairer si je peux dire sur
le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable ce texte comme
l'a dit le président Longeon fait
l'objet d'un examen partager de nos deux
commissions laquelle j'ajouterai
également un avis de la commission de la
de la culture notre rapporteur pour la
commission des affaires économiques
Patrick Chauvet en charge de l'examen de
cet article sur les procédures
d'urbanisme les réseaux d'énergie et les
soutiens budgétaires nous traversons une
crise énergétique sans précédent si ce
n'est pas un scoop en France comme dans
le monde qui met sous tension notre
approvisionnement énergétique notre
compétitivité économique je crois que
nous sommes pas au bout de l'histoire
mais aussi on le voit bien notre
cohésion sociale au travers des
collectivités territoriales en
particulier ce texte doit répondre en
conséquence à de nombreuses attentes
c'est la seconde fois madame la ministre
que vous nous que nous vous recevons en
quelques mois la dernière fois en
juillet vous aviez été interrogé par
notre collègue Daniel Grémillet qui sera
pas non plus muet aujourd'hui président
du groupe d'études énergie et alors
rapporteur pour notre commission sur le
projet de loi portant en mesure
d'urgence pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat auront nous annonce par ailleurs
un projet de loi sur le nucléaire et un
autre évidemment sur la programmation
énergétique aussi ma première question
est-elle simple
légifère-t-on de trop trop vite dans le
désordre vous comprenez qu'on aurait
préféré avoir le chemin avant d'avoir la
voiture pour savoir qu'elle puissance de
voiture on doit mettre sur le chemin
pour arriver au but
par d'autres cette voilà cette image un
peu rapide voilà pouvez-vous d'ailleurs
nous préciser où en est la préparation
des prochains textes je pense au
nucléaire je pense à la PPE car nous
sommes impatients et c'est peu de le
dire de pouvoir nous en saisir notre
commission a adopter à ce propos à
l'unanimité un rapport complet sur le
nucléaire et l'hydrogène en juillet de
cette année et c'est notre commission
qui a fait adopter en 2019 avec la
commission des affaires économiques de
projet national le principe de la future
loi quinquennale sur l'énergie ces
sujets nous tiennent donc
particulièrement à hacker quant à ce
texte j'en partage évidemment l'objectif
qui est celui du développement des
énergies renouvelables nous le
partageons pleinement même si nous avons
comme l'a dit le président des questions
sur la méthode d'ailleurs il nous semble
que l'étude d'impact du projet de loi
est assez lacunaire sur un certain
nombre de sujets or il nous faut
légiférer en connaissance de cause
c'est-à-dire informer de toutes les
conséquences des dispositions que vous
proposez l'article 18 par exemple
propose ni plus ni moins le président
vient d'en parler que d'utiliser la
facture d'électricité des Français comme
levier d'acceptation des projets
d'énergie renouvelables mais on ne
connaît ni le périmètre concerné ni le
coût global de cette mesure ni la façon
dont il sera financé s'agissant de la
concertation les collectivités les
professionnels les associations ont
également regretté son caractère
lacunaire alors que article 3 refond
profondément les documents d'urbanisme
et l'article 6 les raccordements au
réseau voilà pour la méthode quant au
fond je partage l'objectif je
m'interroge simplement sur le calendrier
sur la tempolat temporalité sur le
calibrage au fond une question
d'interpelle les mesures proposées qui
sont utiles et nécessaires ne sont-elles
pas peut-être en deçà de nos besoins
face à la crise énergétique le texte
présente plusieurs angles morts en effet
rien n'est dit ou si peu sur
l'hydroélectricité sur le biogaz sur les
biocarburants le bois énergie ou encore
l'hydrogène certes le caractère
renouvelable de ces énergies ou
technologie est souvent débattue à
l'échelon européen mais pour autant ne
doit-on pas en parler puisqu'elles sont
très utiles notamment dans nos
territoires ruraux et que dire de
l'agrovoltaïsme dont on parlera
probablement au travers des questions
pourtant identifier comme une priorité
par le Président de la République
lui-même dans son discours de
Saint-Nazaire le 22 septembre dernier en
15 jours le gouvernement aurait pu
rajouter ce sujet à ce texte alors que
le Sénat vous le savez examinera ce soir
et demain sa propre proposition de loi
adoptée à l'unanimité par nos
commissions la semaine passée donnant
ainsi une suite législative concrète à
une résolution du président Longeot et
de notre collègue Jean-Pierre Moga ma
question est donc assez directe
reprendrez-vous les travaux du Sénat sur
ce sujet voilà madame la ministre vous
savez l'intérêt que l'on porte à
l'énergie qui est la colonne vertébrale
de notre économie un des trois piliers
de notre souveraineté c'est évidemment
crucial pour les ménages c'est crucial
pour la compétitivité de nos entreprises
et nous sommes impatients donc de vous
entendre voilà madame la ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs après des mois de concertation
et des changes nourris avec l'ensemble
des acteurs associatifs et économiques
voici donc venus le temps du Parlement
le temps pour le Parlement de se prendre
sur le premier texte de ce quinquennat
qui vise à apporter sa pierre à
l'objectif ambitieux fixé par le
président de la République celui de
faire de la France le premier grand pays
industriel à sortir de sa dépendance aux
énergies fossiles ce texte il répond à
une double urgence celle du dérèglement
climatique qui exige une action radicale
de notre part vous le savez le GIEC ne
nous donne en effet que trois ans à
l'échelle de la planète pour commencer à
baisser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et je veux rappeler que la France
fait partie des quelques pays sur la
planète avoir commencé à baissé ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
vous le savez nous devons aller plus
loin puisqu'il faut doubler le rythme de
de ces émissions la deuxième urgence
c'est d'éviter une rupture
d'approvisionnement dans les mois et
années qui viennent là aussi vous le
savez la faible disponibilité de notre
parc nucléaire et hydraulique d'ailleurs
pour des raisons de sécheresse conjugués
à la crise ukrainienne fragilise notre
système énergétique au-delà c'est aussi
l'avenir de notre parc nucléaire qui se
pose au regard de la durée de
fonctionnement de nos réacteurs donc
beaucoup arriveront à 60 ans autour de
203540 je rappelle que notre parc a été
construit initialement pour durer 40 ans
cela implique de prendre des décisions
au plus tôt aujourd'hui 2/3 de notre
consommation d'énergie et d'origine
fossile et importées et je veux dissiper
ici un mythe nous n'avons jamais jamais
été à un quelconque mémoire de notre
histoire depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale autonome et indépendant
énergétiquement nous avons toujours été
dépendants d'énergie bienvenue pour
l'essentiel de l'étranger et la
situation avec la Russie nous rappelle
que nous pouvons être dépendants de pays
qui ne sont pas nos alliés qui ne
partagent pas nos valeurs et qui
utilisent ce levier pour nous atteindre
économiquement et politiquement notre
programme électronucléaire nous a permis
de réduire une partie de cette
dépendance c'est vrai pour l'électricité
mais nous restons très dépendants en
matière de transport et de chaleur si
nous voulons atteindre la neutralité
carbone l'enjeu est donc de réduire ces
deux tiers d'énergie fossile que nous ne
produisons pas nous-mêmes et qui
contribuent à la fois à notre dépendance
et au réchauffement climatique
c'est pourquoi je vais être très clair
sur le combat que nous voulons mener
notre combat ce n'est pas d'opposer le
nucléaire renouvelable ce n'est pas non
plus d'opposer la biodiversité au climat
tant la biodiversité est affectée par le
dérèglement climatique notre combat
c'est celui des énergies bas carbone
contre les énergies fossiles car ce sont
les énergies fossiles qui sont à
l'origine du réchauffement climatique
entre autres et des principales
atteintes à la biodiversité l'étude
future énergétique 2050 des experts de
RTE rappelle que nous disposons de trois
leviers pour sortir des énergies
fossiles le premier c'est les économies
d'énergie c'est de bon sens au travers
de l'efficacité énergétique et de la
sobriété énergétique RTE fixe un
objectif de réduction de 40% de notre
consommation d'énergie d'ici 2050 vous
savez que j'ai présenté le 6 octobre
dernier avec la première ministre un
plan sobriété pour faire une première
marche de 10%, la réduction de 40% de
notre consommation d'énergie c'est un
défi sans pareil il suppose à la fois de
travailler sur la sobriété c'est à dire
le changement de nos usages de la
manière de nous transporter des
bâtiments d'organiser la ville et c'est
pour ça que ce plan sobriété il concerne
l'État les collectivités locales les
grandes entreprises ceux qui sont
capables d'organiser au fond beaucoup de
déplacements et beaucoup d'usages de
bâtiments des Français mais c'est aussi
l'efficacité énergétique la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
l'électrification de l'industrie
l'électrification des transports ou
d'autres technologies bas carbone que
nous devons mener le deuxième levé c'est
le développement massif d'énergie bas
carbone ça peut être des énergies
renouvelables ça peut être le programme
nucléaire et comme vous l'avez indiqué
un projet de loi sur l'accélération des
procédures administratives et je parle
bien de procédure administratives en
matière de un nouveau projet nucléaire
vous sera présenté dans quelques
semaines je présenterai en conseil des
ministres début novembre je veux
insister sur la conclusion centrale de
l'étude de RTE qui est atteindre la
neutralité carbone est impossible
sans un accroissement massif des
énergies renouvelables même dans un
scénario de relance du nucléaire le
texte que vous examinerez dans les
prochains jours répond à cette nécessité
il est le volet législatif d'un plan
énergies renouvelable que je déploie
depuis le mois de juin sur le volet
réglementaire avec des décrets pris cet
été et sur le volet organisationnel avec
une circulaire à destination des préfets
pour faire de cet objectif une priorité
de leur action et un renforcement des
effectifs des services de l'État qui
instruent si une réponse monsieur le
Président qui instruisent les procédures
d'autorisation dans le budget en cours
d'examen à l'Assemblée nationale vous
avez raison il faut renforcer les
effectifs et nous le ferons à hauteur
d'une dizaine de TP c'est énorme à
l'échelon des
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
mobilisées pour instruire ces dossiers
ces mesures elles ont permis de
débloquer 10 gigawatts d'énergie solaire
éolienne et un térawatt de gaz
renouvelables dans les on va dire deux
prochaines années
ce plan énergie renouvelable il concerne
toutes les filières renouvelables toutes
les filières renouvelables qu'il
s'agisse de la géothermie sur lequel
nous allons annoncer je vais annoncer
prochainement un plan spécifique en
passant par le biogaz par l'hydraulique
par la biomasse par le photovoltaïque
thermique et je vais vous passer
la liste de toutes les énergies
renouvelables à notre disposition mais
certains éléments sont d'ordre on va
dire
réglementaire d'autres sont d'ordre
législatif et donc très clairement nous
avons dans le projet législatif retenu
les éléments essentiels qui nous étaient
remontés par les filières pour être
traités au niveau législatif je suis
évidemment ouverte à ouvrir le projet à
d'autres formes d'énergie renouvelables
si tenté qui est on voit qu'il y a des
obstacles législatifs alors
développement
les objectifs que nous allons nous
donner seront ajustées et voter dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation énergie
climat que vous avez mentionné madame la
première madame la Présidente
et qui devra être adopté à force d'avoir
des femmes puissantes on finit par s'y
perdre qui devra être adopté par le
Parlement en 2023 à l'issue d'une grande
concertation nationale que je lancerai
en fin de semaine donc là vous savez que
dans l'ordre de mise en oeuvre en fait
tout cela est très organisé nous avons
un débat public qui va démarrer d'ici la
fin de semaine sur la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie ce débat va se
dérouler jusqu'au mois de janvier il
fera ensuite l'objet de travaux pour
définir la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie qui vous sera soumise dans une
loi probablement à la fin du premier
semestre 2023
et ce sur quoi nous travaillons
aujourd'hui c'est des projets de loi qui
nous sont nécessaires pour accélérer les
procédures tant nous savons que nous
allons avoir besoin de tous les leviers
pour accélérer l'implantation d'énergie
bacarbonne et que ces procédures sont
sur le chemin critique de ces
productions d'énergie pas carbone avant
de rentrer dans le détail de ce texte
permettez-moi d'abord de vous remercier
collectivement pour les nombreux
échanges que nous avons eu depuis la
rentrée et pour le travail préparatoire
qui sera j'en suis sûr précieux pour la
suite de nos débats je remercie
évidemment particulièrement les deux
rapporteurs Didier mentelli et Patrick
Chauvet qui ont mené de nombreuses
auditions qui permettront d'enrichir le
texte et les présidents des deux
commissions Sophie prima et
Jean-François Longeot dont je sais
l'engagement sur ces questions
ce texte il vise donc à court terme à
lever des verrous administratifs et de
procédures pour diviser par deux les
délais de déploiement des projets de
production d'énergie bas carbone donc
c'est une réponse l'objectif c'est de
diviser par deux les procédures les
délais de procédure la France est le
seul pays de l'Union européenne à ne pas
avoir atteint son objectif national de
développement des énergies renouvelables
ça va nous coûter 500 millions d'euros
cette année je pense que c'est une
raison supplémentaire d'agir et vous le
savez à l'heure actuelle il faut en
moyenne deux fois plus de temps pour
impact un parc solaire ou pour un parc
éolien en mer par rapport à nos
principaux voisins européens deux fois
plus de temps c'est pas un temps de
travaux c'est un temps de procédure et
de contentieux en réponse à cela nous
proposons donc d'agir sur quatre leviers
le premier levier c'est l'accélération
des procédures en prévoyant par exemple
un raccordement au réseau sans attendre
que le projet soit achevé pour entamer
les démarches cela peut permettre de
faire gagner une à plusieurs années
le deuxième levier c'est de libérer le
foncier en mobilisant en priorité les
terrains déjà artificiels à Elysées ou
dégrader des parkings des friches des
anciennes décharges aux carrières des
bordures d'autoroutes etc ces mesures
vont permettre de libérer des espaces et
de doubler notre puissance solaire
actuelle elle s'inscrit pleinement de
l'objectif d'avoir le moins d'impact
possible sur la biodiversité je souhaite
que nous allions plus loin dans ce texte
et je sais que vous travaillez déjà des
propositions pour répondre à cette
impératif de concilier développement des
projets de production d'énergie et
protection de la biodiversité le
troisième levier c'est de beaucoup mieux
concerter en permettant en particulier
pour les projets éoliens en mer un débat
mutualisé sur chaque façade maritime
pour décider avec les territoires avec
leurs habitants en tenant compte des
différents usages de la location de ces
territoires plutôt que de multiplier les
discussions sur chaque projet et de
laisser finalement les porteurs de
projets arriver avec des projets qui
sont souvent assez ficelés pour
découvrir qu'il y a un grand problème au
moment de la concertation
le quatrième et dernier levier c'est
l'acceptabilité des projets d'énergie
renouvelables c'est essentiel car
reprendre en main notre destin
énergétique implique d'avoir des
infrastructures de production
énergétique près de chez soi je voudrais
juge reviens à l'instant sur la
concertation et sur la planification on
sait tous que c'est un levier puissant
d'acceptabilité des projets au sein des
territoires sa place est probablement
dans la loi énergie climat ce que ça est
lié à la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie mais je j'entends les
velléités de prendre les devants de
cette assemblée donc on va essayer de
faire au mieux mais voilà ils ont en
tête que dans 9 mois rebelote ou dans 7
mois rebelote avec la loi énergie climat
j'ai commencé par le début non parce
qu'il faut commencer par le débat public
et vous savez que le calendrier est
assez incompressible par rapport à la
fin de la PPE précédente le quatrième et
dernier levier c'est l'acceptabilité des
projets d'énergie renouvelables c'est
essentiel car reprendre en main notre
destin énergétique implique d'avoir des
infrastructures de production
énergétique près de chez soi près de
chez soi c'est donc dans sa cour nous
devons donc apprendre à apprendre à
cohabiter massivement avec des
infrastructures de production d'énergie
alors que nous avions pris l'habitude de
faire faire l'essentiel de nos besoins
énergétiques de lui faire porter par
d'autres pays à l'autre bout du monde la
mesure que nous proposons doit permettre
au territoire de bénéficier de la valeur
créée par les projets d'énergie
renouvelables qu'ils accueillent dans
l'intérêt général de notre pays mais
aussi pour améliorer l'attractivité de
ces territoires sur ce sujet là on est
très humble on a proposé un premier
dispositif mais nous sommes très à
l'écoute des idées que vous pourriez
avoir pour l'améliorer et je pense qu'en
tant qu' assemblée du territoire vous
avez certainement des idées sur la façon
de d'avancer sur ces sujets là ce plan
énergie renouvelable j'entends le mener
en prenant en compte deux impératifs
essentiels la préservation de la
biodiversité l'association des
territoires et je tiens à le dire
d'emblée accélérer ne veut ni dire
rabaisser les standards de protection de
notre biodiversité et nous ne faisons
pas dans ce projet nous ne le faisons
pas ni outrepasser les territoires qui
seront des partenaires essentiels pour
réarmer notre pays énergétiquement nous
posons les fondations d'impact
territorial énergétique ce n’est pas un
hasard si le gouvernement a fait le
choix de discuter le texte en première
lecture au Sénat notre vision de la
planification énergétique n'est pas une
planification descendante la
planification nous appelons de nos vœux
est une planification qui remet les
collectivités locales et les territoires
au centre en responsabilité cette grande
mobilisation est indispensable car cette
mutation est tellement vaste et touche
tellement de sujets qu'elle ne peut se
faire par des initiatives individuel non
coordonnées alors concrétisons ensemble
le travail initier depuis plusieurs
semaines j'ai entendu vos différentes
propositions qui s'inscrivent dans
l'esprit de ce texte elle permettront de
l'enrichir mais très clairement je le
dis le gouvernement a évidemment une
ligne rouge c'est celle de complexifier
et d'allonger les procédures parce que
c'est le contraire de l'objet de ce
texte cela irait à contresens de
l'urgence à laquelle nous faisons
collectivement face mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs nous avons la
possibilité d'affirmer la volonté de
notre pays de s'engager dans un
développement
raisonnable massif et industriels les
énergies des carbonées de bâtir les
fondations de notre futur indépendance
énergétique je suis confiante sur le
fait que nous trouverons le chemin du
consensus avec tous ceux qui défendent
la souveraineté énergétique et politique
de notre pays et avec tous ceux qui
veulent lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique car c'est bien tout l'objet
de ce texte je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre je ne sais pas
combien ma collègue a deux demandes de
paroles mais beaucoup j'en ai une
brouette
donc on va commencer par notre
rapporteur
Didier Vandelli
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame la
ministre moi je vais être très court
parce que je voudrais pas prendre tes
l'ensemble des nombreuses questions qui
ne manqueront pas d'être posées par tous
mes collègues je vous exprimer tout
d'abord de regrets un star de ce que
vient de dire la président de la
Commission à faire écho c'est évidemment
que ce texte arrive avant un autre texte
sur sur le nucléaire et puis avant la
PPE mais c'est ainsi on en fera bon
usage malgré tout et puis que ce texte
ne contienne pas a priori donc quand il
est arrivé les autres énergies
renouvelables que nous allons traiter
tous ensemble malgré tout dans ce texte
moi ce que ce que je voudrais dire
simplement c'est que nous plaçons
effectivement les questions de
planification et d'acceptabilité et je
pense que l'acceptabilité est souvent la
conséquence de heureuse de d'une large
concertation le plus dans le monde
possible sur sur les différents dossiers
donc effectivement nous avons travaillé
sur cette question en faisant des
propositions très concrètes que je vais
pas développer ici mais voilà les
collègues pouvant sans doute un syndrome
de questions
moi je souhaiterais simplement que dans
le cadre de cette planification et en
particulier pour l'éolien offshore qui
est une partie importante du texte que
nous puissions dans les semaines et le
temps qui nous sépare de la PPE définir
une ligne qui commune qui puisse prendre
en compte les évolutions technologiques
attendues parce que très clairement la
question de l'acceptabilité rime souvent
avec visibilité que ce soit à terre ou
en mer donc voilà simplement ce que je
voulais dire madame la ministre à ce
stade et je vais laisser bien sûr mon
collègue rapporteur apprendra la parole
et puis ensuite j'espère que tous nos
collègues auront beaucoup beaucoup de
questions c'est pas la peine de réclamer
c'est
Patrick Chauvet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre c'est avec
un grand plaisir que j'effectue
actuellement mon travail de rapporteur
sur ce projet de loi pour la commission
des affaires économiques pour avoir été
rapporteur sur la Loi sur l'aménagement
du Rhône en janvier dernier je partage
observation faite par notre présidente
sur l'inflation normative dans le
secteur de l'énergie c'est une
préoccupation car les textes
s'enchaînent et se juxtaposent sans
qu'un cap clair ne soit fixé nous
attendons beaucoup de la loi caté
quinquennale sur l'énergie sur ce point
au cours de mes travaux préparateurs et
préparatoires actuels j'ai entendu 45
organismes et 100 personnalité et reçu
75 contributions leur constat est
convergent l'objectif du texte est
largement partagé mais la méthode est
tout aussi critiquée elle est par
beaucoup d'élus locaux qui déplorent le
non respect de certaines compétences
locales il faut davantage de
subsidiarité sur le plan de des
compétences elle est aussi par beaucoup
de professionnels dans ceux du gaz et de
la chaleur qui critique un texte jugé
tout électrique il faut davantage de
neutralité sur le plan des technologies
et que dire des angles morts bien
évoqués par notre Présidente j'ai
rapporté trois textes sur
l'hydrauliquericité au Sénat et j'ai
toujours été stupéfait de la frisolite
freelosité pardon du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet pourtant cardinal il y aura-t-il
un projet de loi spécifique sur nos
concessions hydroélectriques embarquer
les collectivités et développer toutes
les sources de renouvelables voilà deux
de nos préoccupations parce que
l'objectif d'un autre commission est de
contribuer positivement à l'examen du
texte tout en l'excurgence de
disposition inopérantes juridiquement ou
peu acceptable économiquement ou
socialement je vous souhaiterais vous
poser quelques questions plus précises
sur le projet de loi sur l'article 3 la
possibilité donnée à l'état de modifier
unilatéralement les documents
d'urbanisme est très mal vécu par les
élus locaux si l'on comprend bien qu'il
faille accélérer sur les projets
d'énergie renouvelables ne pourrait-on
pas faire davantage confiance aux
collectivités territoriales sur
l'article 6 la faculté pour le
gouvernement de légiférer par voie
d'ordonnance est très large en effet il
pourrait modifier tout à la fois les
conditions d'accès les schémas de
développement ou le tarif d'utilisation
des réseaux pouvez-vous nous rassurer
sur l'intention du gouvernement
entendez-vous bien conserver les
réductions tarifaires qui bénéficient à
nos producteurs renouvelables et à nos
consommateurs électro intensifs et
pourquoi ne pas procéder à des
modifications législatives directement
dans le texte comme pour la suppression
envisagée de la contribution des
communes sur l'article 16 la possibilité
pour le gouvernement d'implanter des
ouvrages de raccordement en zone
littoral doit s'accompagner des
garde-fous nécessaires les communes ne
devraient-elles pas être associées et ne
faudrait-il pas exonérer des ouvrages du
décompte de l'objectif 0 artificiel
artificialisation nette Lausanne sur
l'article 17 les contrats d'achat de
long terme sont très utiles pour
promouvoir les énergies renouvelables
tout en réduisant mais pourquoi
s'arrêter à l'électricité que
pensez-vous détendre le dispositif au
biogaz sur l'article 18 le tarif le
rabais tarifaire proposé au consommateur
à proximité d'installation renouvelables
et très curieux je ne dispose toujours
pas d'éléments chiffrés exhaustif sur ce
dispositif or il sera pris en charge par
les fournisseurs puis par les
contribuables via les charges de gestion
du service public de l'énergie je ne
dispose toujours pas non plus des
éléments précis sur son champ
concernera-t-il bien toutes les énergies
renouvelables y compris gazières et
s'appliquera-t-il aux installations
existantes enfin sur l'article 19 le
contrat d'expérimentation doit permettre
de soutenir le gaz bas carbone mais
exclut les autres gaz renouvelables que
le biogaz c'est dommage qu'à l'ensemble
de ces gaz nécessite d'être promu au
moins à titre expérimental d'autant que
la crise gaziaire nous oblige de sortir
de notre dépendance au gaz russe ne
devrait-on pas compléter le dispositif
en ce sens pour conclure je veux dire
ici l'État très positif dans lequel je
m'inscris pour mener à bien mes travaux
mon travail notre travail se veut
concret rationnel pragmatique avec mon
collègue Didier mandeli que je salue
nous sommes d'ailleurs tout à fait en
phase et la voix du Sénat est claire et
unitaire sur ce texte je souhaite
consolider ce qui peut l'être et
corriger ce qui doit l'être en gardant
toujours à l'esprit deux impératifs la
simplification des normes cruciales pour
les producteurs d'énergie des carbonés
et la territorialisation des projets
nécessaires à leur insertion locale et
donc leur acceptation sociale c'est
comme cela que nous pourrons progresser
pas à pas dans la réalisation concrète
de nos objectifs énergétiques nationaux
et de nos engagements climatiques
internationaux je vous remercie
je vais donner
président du groupe
Daniel gremillat président du groupe
d'énergie et puis ensuite on vous voilà
merci Madame c'est le président madame
la ministre chers collègue effectivement
on vit une période dans un secteur qui
est très perturbé et je pense que nous
sommes tous
préoccupés par cette situation ma
première question porte donc sur notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement nous avons
adopté un arsenal législatif très
complet dans le cadre de la loi pouvoir
d'achat en juillet et vous avez madame
la ministre fin septembre présenté votre
plan de sobriété énergétique est-il
suffisant pour passer l'hiver ou
envisagez-vous de prendre de nouvelles
mesures légatives ou réglementaires
ma deuxième question concerne l'énergie
nucléaire et hydrogène en étant issu
pour l'essentiel la stratégie française
pour un hydrogène décarboné se fondent
sur une production nationale d'hydrogène
alimentée par nos réacteurs si c'est une
bonne chose dans notre rapport sur
nucléaire et hydrogène évoqué par notre
Président nous avons plaidé pour
renforcer ce couplage entre le nucléaire
et l'hydrogène en implant lever
rapidement plus rapidement plus de
verrous en effet en matière d'hydrogène
la stratégie est perfectible la
législation parcellaire et les
financements insuffisants les 1,6
milliards d'euros manquants pour le
cofinancement des pièces ont-ils été
trouvés et pourquoi si peu prendre en
compte ce vecteur énergétique d'avenir
dans ce projet de loi sachant madame la
ministre vous le savez très bien que
l'avenir est
ceux qui seront à la manœuvre sur
l'indépendance énergétique hydrogène
c'est en train de se jouer maintenant ma
dernière question
a très à l'hydrogène à
l'hydroélectricité pardon sur laquelle
nous avons fait adopter une proposition
de loi en 2021 reprise dans la loi
climat résilience quelques mois plus
tard nous avons obtenu de belles
avancées avec la mise en place d'un
médiateur de l'hydroélectricité pour
répondre au litige et d'un portail
national de hydroacticité pour
centraliser les demandes ils sont
opérationnels depuis juin ce faisant
nous avons appliqué concrètement notre
mission de simplification des normes à
laquelle nous sommes très attachés
et là je suis très surpris parce que il
ne figure absolument pas dans le projet
que vous nous présentez ce concernant la
possibilité de développement
hydroélectricité sur nos territoires
merci
on va vous laisser répondre puis ensuite
on rentrera dans le tunnel de toutes les
questions voilà nombreuses
alors
peut-être
revenir un instant sur effectivement la
planification sur l'éolien marins qui
est un enjeu qui est je dirais assez
aujourd'hui sur lequel nous nous voulons
nous voulons progresser je vais d'abord
dire ici que l'objectif tel que nous
l'avons projeté mais ça sera la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
de le préciser mais on sait bien que les
grandes mailles sont pas erronées c'est
40 GW d'éolien marin aujourd'hui tous
les projets pour lesquels il y a eu des
appels à
projets lancé se situe à moins de 40 km
des côtes et ce sont tous du posé parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la
capacité à mettre du flottant
enfin on n'a pas aujourd'hui au plan
international aucun aucune installation
flottante qui
qui fonctionne de manière industrielle
on a des projets qui sont expérimentaux
on en a un en Atlantique on en a un en
Méditerranée on en a
deux ans chez nos voisins
je pense que c'est en Norvège ou en
école j'ai pu en tête mais mais on n'a
pas de preuve de concept on va dire
étayé on peut faire l'hypothèse
raisonnable qu'on en aura une je veux
dire on a vu les convergences sur
l'éoliennes sur l'éolien marins etc mais
on peut aussi faire l'hypothèse que ça
n'arrivera pas avant 2030 2035 grosso
modo ce qui veut dire que il faut agir
sur
l'éolien posée et nous n'avons pas la
chance comme nos petits camarades qui
sont en Manche et en
et en mer Baltique d'avoir
la capacité à mettre du poser où on veut
nous avons assez vite des fonds marins
nous avons en Méditerranée des canyones
et donc on est pas tout à fait en
capacité de mettre de mettre autre chose
dans un délire rapide donc on voit bien
à la fois
un problème d'entendre parce que j'étais
à Saint-Nazaire et j'ai entendu les élus
qui nous disent l'image est pas
exactement celle qu'on nous avait vendu
et je l'entends
je me suis même plongée avec intérêt
dans la décision de la collectivité
locale vendéenne qui s'était engagé sur
ce projet-là pour constater
qu'effectivement il y avait des écarts
par rapport à ce qui était attendu donc
je pense qu'il faut dire la vérité et
mesurer la réalité des impacts de ces
projets mais il faut être aussi
conscient que ce sont les projets qui en
taille sont les plus gros à notre main
et en particulier les plus efficaces
aussi et donc là aussi c'est une
question de qu'est-ce que où on passe
notre ligne d'acceptabilité en ayant
toujours en tête que si nous voulons
avoir cette indépendance énergétique il
va falloir trouver je dis 40 gigawatts
c'est peut-être pas la vérité c'est
peut-être 35 c'est peut-être 50 mais
enfin ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est pas
3 gigawatts et donc ça veut dire
plusieurs dizaines de projets ensuite il
y a une programmation dans le temps et
là encore il va falloir être attentif à
ne pas repousser la programmation dans
le temps en disant finalement tout ce
qui va arriver va arriver après 2035
parce que c'est faire peser beaucoup de
responsabilités sur nos successeurs donc
il faut agir maintenant il faut accepter
de faire certains projets il faut
regarder comment le faire de la manière
la plus concertée possible en en prenant
en compte les conflits d'usage il faut
avoir en tête que lorsqu'on repousse ses
installations on pose aussi des
questions en termes de voix maritime et
que ça résout pas complètement les
sujets en termes de pêche et il y a
aussi des enjeux de défense etc diverses
et donc voilà c'est finalement il faut
éviter de repousser pour pour mieux
sauter parce que le risque c'est de se
retrouver en situation de plus grande
dépendance mais je pense que les
questions qui sont posées sur la
planification et qui me sont remontés de
différents
directions sont parfaitement légitimes
et voilà moi j'invite à ce qu'on trouve
un point d'équilibre probablement que la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
est une façon aussi de dire quel est
grosso modo la maille qu'on veut
atteindre et sache est étant enfin
prenant en compte les projets qui sont
déjà partis ou peut-on positionner et
quelle est la part de ce qui est en
proximité des côtes et de ce qui est
plus loin et assez vite on les chiffres
seront têtus je pense
le sur la question de pour Monsieur
Chauvet pourquoi pas d'autres énergies
renouvelables parce que toutes les
énergies renouvelables sont bien
couvertes par le Titre 1 donc il y a
effectivement des mesures sur l'éolien
marin pour les raisons que je précise
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu un certain
nombre de remontées en disant vos
projets arrivent tout ficeler il y a un
problème de concertation et de conflit
d'usage il faut remonter la concertation
il faut améliorer la planification on en
tient compte mais le Titre 1 porte sur
toutes les énergies renouvelables
s'agissant du biogaz je veux dire ici
que je n'ai aucune demande de mesure
législative de la part de la filière
biogaz si ce n'est la question de
l'article 19 que nous avons mis sur les
gaz baccarbonne le reste est en couvert
et si ce n'est la question de la PPA
parce qu'effectivement ça s'est remonté
après présentation enfin après que le
projet soit soit parti et donc oui on
est effectivement ouvert à ce que les
peurs
agreement mauvais français soit ouvert à
des projets qui soient pas uniquement
électrique je sais qu'on y travaille
d'ailleurs à des rédactions qui soient
de qualité
sur la question des compétences locales
c'est un sujet sur lequel il me semble
qu'on peut sortir par le haut en
considérant que il y a une attente aussi
des mers de ne pas avoir à modifier tous
les documents d'urbanisme quand ils sont
prêts à accueillir des énergies non
renouvelables sur leur territoire et
qu'il y a des écarts par rapport à leur
document d'urbanisme donc je pense que
le point de sortie c'est de s'accorder
sur l'idée que peut-être qu'on peut
déroger au document d'urbanisme dès lors
que l'assemblée qui les a voté et
d'accord pour déroger pour gagner du
temps et pas refaire tout le tunnel de
mise en place des documents d'urbanisme
et donc ça remet la compétence du côté
des collectivités locales sur l'article
6 c'est une rédaction en dur qui vous
sera proposée on est en train de
finaliser l'amendement gouvernemental
sur l'article 17 j'ai répondu sur
l'article 18 la redistribution elle
s'applique bien à toutes les énergies
renouvelables et encore une fois je le
redis il y a une grande ouverture de
notre part avoir discussion sur des
leviers pour
position complémentaire
y compris les installations existantes
tout à fait
sur l'article 19 donc pour nous le
biogaz est bien couvert aujourd'hui et
donc c'est un article qui vise à couvrir
ce qui n'est pas aujourd'hui couvert
dans les appels à projets et après il y
a tout le travail qu'on mène avec la
creux pour faire des appels à projets
sur différentes technologies mais vous
savez qu'on y travaille monsieur
grimillier sur
le l'hydrogène donc il y a tout le tout
le combat que nous menons au niveau
européen pour obtenir la reconnaissance
d'un hydrogène bas carbone et pas
seulement fondée sur des énergies
renouvelables il y a le travail que nous
avons mené sur les ipci et vous savez
que nous avons été le pays qui a
remporté le plus de projets PC oui de
mémoire 10 projets sur les premiers 41
qui ont été annoncés qui vont donner
lieu à la construction
d'autant de d'usine nouvelle
électroviseur puis la combustible donc
surtout les maillons de de la chaîne et
là encore nous avons 10 milliards
d'euros qui sont consacrés dans le plan
France 2030 à l'hydrogène et à la
décarbonation qui s'ajoute au plan
d'investissement d'avenir qui avait déjà
prévu des enveloppes importantes pour
l'hydrogène et à ma connaissance mais je
suis verte pour considérer toute
proposition nous n'avons pas besoin de
mesures législatives sur l'hydrogène sur
l'hydroélectrique là la première
ministre a été claire dans son
discours devant vous la semaine dernière
sur la politique énergétique puisqu'elle
a indiqué qu'elle souhaitait
effectivement
prendre assez vite mais vous savez qu'il
y a une opération en cours de montée au
capital de DF qui qui
qui se qui se mène et qui doit nous
permettre d'atteindre 100% de sécuriser
les concessions hydrauliques dans la
durée chez cette opérateur et par
ailleurs le gouvernement ne compte pas
se priver des opportunités offertes par
la petite hydroélectricité pour
contribuer aux objectifs d'augmentation
de notre production des carbonées comme
vous l'indiquez la PPE promu cette
technologie et prévoit d'ailleurs des
appels d'offres dédiées la creux a
délibéré le 12 mai 2022 sur la quatrième
période d'appel d'offe portant la
réalisation et l'exploitation
d'installation
hydroélectrique pour une attribution de
2,3 mégawatts alors on est loin des 35
MW attendu mais un nouvel appel d'offre
sera lancé en 2023 pour la future
campagne et j'ajoute que le gouvernement
a pris le 28 juin 2022 un décret fixant
les modalités d'application de
l'expérimentation relative à
l'institution du médiateur de
l'hydroélectricité en Occitanie afin de
réduire les frictions sur ces sur ces
projets donc voilà on imprimante on a
des appels à projets là encore sur cet
aspect petit hydroélectricité on n'a pas
le sentiment qu'il y avait
de problématiques au-delà de ce que j'ai
indiqué c'est la première ministre qui a
annoncé qu'un nouveau cadre législatif
sera proposé afin de permettre de
relancer rapidement les investissements
dans nos barrages vous savez que il y a
à peu près 6 milliards d'euros à
investir pour permettre d'augmenter le
potentiel
d'hydraulique existant sans passer par
une remise en concurrence
je vais donner la parole à écrire à elle
rigole si vous pouviez poser vos
questions en deux minutes pas plus parce
que moi j'ai 15 15 questions ça fait 30
minutes déjà puis je crois que Sophie on
a autant donc voilà
la parole est rigole merci monsieur le
président madame la présidente madame la
ministre je vais revenir justement moi
sur la petite
hydro-électricité le futur projet de loi
relatif aux énergies renouvelables à
l'ambition d'accélérer donc les projets
nécessaires à la transition écologique
si le solaire terrestre et l'éolien en
mer trouve une part importante dans le
texte initial on voit que la petite
hydroélectricité n'est pas envisagée
comme un outil de décarbonation notre
production d'énergie pourtant la loi
énergie climat 2019 permettait de
mobiliser la petite hydroélectricité
face à l'urgence écologique et
climatique ensuite la loi climat est
résilience a fortement limitée les
destructions d'ouvrages hydrauliques
conservant ainsi des retenues d'eau
anciennes dans nos rivières et ruisseaux
alors que les projets de parc éolien et
solaire sont systématiquement contestés
le petit hydraulique est toujours mieux
accepté notamment dans des zones peu
denses alors bien conscient que je parle
ici que d'une énergie avec un potentiel
de production certes limité j'aimerais
connaître quels sont les principaux
arguments sur lesquels vous pouvez
appuyer ou en tous les cas à
l'administration peut s'appuyer pour ne
pas bénéficier d'équipements
patrimoniaux déjà existants dans les
montagnes des outils de décarbonation de
notre énergie je vous remercie
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues madame les ministres je suis
actuellement rapporteur donc sur la
proposition loi en faveur du
développement de l'agris voltaïsme ce
texte donc vise à donner une orientation
stratégique un cadre légal un soutien
budgétaire donc à cette technologie
provateuse l'enjeu est de soutenir des
projets porteurs d'externalité positive
pour nos agriculteurs mais aussi de
contrôler et de réguler des projets
Libye pour ce faire 25 organismes et 50
personnalités ont été auditionnées notre
notre travail c'est voulu sérieux et
complet c'est d'ailleurs appuyé sur la
PPR de du président Longeot et de notre
collègue Jean-Pierre Moga j'espère qu'en
tant que ce travail aboutira êtes-vous
prête à le reprendre la définition que
nous proposons ici du travail de l'ADEME
et en envie de par le enrichi le par
l'apport donc du Sénat peut servir de
cadre de référence la procédure
urbanistique les garanties financières
les soutiens budgétaires sont tout à
fait opérationnels et n'attendre qu'être
appliquée nous sommes donc attentifs à
votre réponse et à l'appréciation que
vous faites de ces orientations et de ce
texte
merci je suis dans la parole à
Jean-Baptiste
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre donc cette loi d'accélération
des énergies renouvelables évidemment
est nécessaire au gouvernement mais je
vous dirais qu'elle est aussi attendue
par de nombreux élus
elle permettra je l'espère de résoudre
de certains problèmes entre la volonté
gouvernementale et le blocage que nous
avons localement avec
CNPN c'est pas local mais avec les Dréal
dans le titre 2
vous parlez de zone anthropisée et c'est
ce qui est retenu dans les strates en
général donc toiture friche industrielle
il y a pas de souci mais là on est sur
des zones urbanisées
vous envisagez vous ouvrez la porte pour
les zones maritimes en parlant des
Salines qui sont
abandonnées et qui deviennent des zones
anthropisées pourquoi pas vous parler de
la zone montagne en acceptant la
discontinuité et la construction c'est
une nécessité
mais nulle part on parle des zones
rurales c'est le milieu qui va apporter
les surfaces nécessaires par rapport à
nos ambitions parce que les toitures et
les friches industrielles ne suffiront
pas zone rurale où on a pas outré peu
dans un anthropisée ou la plupart des
communes se sont engagées à ne pas
utiliser d'espaces agricoles et donc
c'est la zone naturelle qui va donner la
possibilité à ces projets et à ce moment
là je pense qu'on doit aborder ces
projets sous deux aspects il y a la
production d'énergie renouvelable c'est
la volonté de l'État et on y souscrit
sans souci mais il y a aussi la valeur
économique qui est particulièrement
importante et le partage de cette valeur
qui est initié dans la loi et pour que
ce partage ait lieu mais il faut
peut-être qu'on est
des critères de sélection et je me
permets de vous donner l'exemple que
nous nous appliquons en zone Sud région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur c'est une des
critères à sécurité mis en place par le
Parc naturel régional du Verdon qui ont
été repris aujourd'hui par l'Union
régionale des communes forestières si ce
sont les zones naturelles qui donnent la
possibilité de construire ses parcs
photovoltaïques ou autre chose il faut
qu'il y ait plusieurs critères qui
soient concomitants peu d'impact sur la
biodiversité tout le monde le conçoit
peu d'impact visuels dans le sud nous
sommes une région particulièrement
touristique et c'est important peu
d'impact sur la forêt puisque c'est la
zone naturelle qui donne la recette donc
il faut que les bois qu'on sacrifient ce
sont des bois de peu de valeur
économiques mais surtout le quatrième
critère des terrains communaux de façon
à ce que le partage de la valeur soit
vraiment réel
donc ça donne un retour pour les
habitants sur le budget communal ça
permet aux communes rurales de
développer une politique de maîtrise de
l'énergie qui est souhaitable et qui est
souhaité par ses communes mais qu'elles
ne peuvent pas développer parce qu'elles
n'ont pas les moyens je vous rappelle
que le kilowatt qui coûte le moins cher
et qui pollue le moins c'est celui qu'on
a pas besoin de produire
un retour pour la forêt puisque c'est la
forêt qui donne la recette et ça permet
aux communes de mieux protéger leur
forêt aussi bien au niveau sanitaire
qu'au niveau du feu et on a vécu cette
année
et d'engager des politiques de
sylviculture pérenne afin de produire du
bois d'oeuvre on est vertu à tout niveau
il nous reste à faire accepter ces
projets là mais le fait de mettre des
projets participatifs
ça nous donne une possibilité
d'acceptation sociale beaucoup plus
importante et le partage de la valeur il
est vraiment accéléré
donc en fonction de votre réponse je
déposerai la demande en ce sens là et je
vous parle d'expérience puisque demain à
Moissac inaugure un parc photovoltaïque
qui va produire 30 mégawatts nous avons
mis 5 ans
à le mettre en place un arrêt de mie de
réflexion pour construire le projet
trois ans et demi de discussion avec les
services de la Dréal
le corollaire si vous le permettez il a
été déjà soulevé
bon
soit ces terrains-là vont être classés
comme artificialisé et à ce moment-là
c'est plus la peine d'en parler les
communieront pas soit on accepte de
faire comme sur les terrains agricoles
de pas les classer dans ces zones là et
il y a en plus une ambiguïté qui est
forte entre les forêts soumises et les
permis de défrichement
merci j'en pardon de te couper mais on a
beaucoup beaucoup de questions pierre
Kuipers en deux minutes maximum oui j'ai
deux questions donc 4 minutes merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je ma première question
nécessite de votre part des réponses
plus précises alors que vous l'avez pas
abordé un petit peu dans votre
présentation tout à l'heure dans quel
cadre va se dérouler la concertation
nationale sur le mixte énergétique
français alors qu'il y a déjà la loi
vous l'avez dit sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables la loi sur le
nucléaire d'ici la fin de l'année et la
loi de programmation énergie climat
la filière métallisation que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir tout à l'heure au
téléphone ne voit pas clair dans ces
différentes concertations et crainte ne
soit repoussé la PPE alors que l'on a
besoin de visibilité et d'objectifs
forts pour développer la filière méthane
par ailleurs deuxième question plusieurs
préconisations que nous avions suggéré
dans le cas de la mission méthanisation
l'an passé ou abouti dans la dans le
cadre de la loi pouvoir d'achat en
juillet dernier il en va ainsi de la
formation préalable des élus de
l'expérimentation d'un guichet unique de
la consolidation de la planification
nationale comme local pour autant nous
devons aller plus loin nous devons aller
plus loin et pour ma part il est
impératif de relever l'objectif de 10 à
20% de biogaz inscrit parmi les
objectifs d'un politique énergétique
nationale qu'en pensez-vous vous y
engagez-vous dans le cadre de la future
loi quinquennale sur l'énergie je vous
remercie
voilà
une minute Guillaume chevrolier merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Faso aux enjeux de souveraineté
énergétique et de décarbonation notre
économie les particuliers comme les
entreprises veulent installer des
panneaux photovoltaïques vous l'avez
indiqué on est en retard par rapport aux
objectifs de la PPE raccordé au minimum
plus d'un gigawaker par an d'ici 2023
aujourd'hui on est à 400 mégawattheure
le problème crucial c'est la les délais
de raccordement donc il faut améliorer
les procédures de raccordement pour le
photovoltaïque en particulier et pour le
déploiement du panneau photovoltaïque
aussi sur les toitures ça en jette des
problèmes engendre des problèmes au
niveau des assurances notamment pour les
entreprises est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer quelles sont les pistes de
réflexion pour résoudre ces difficultés
deuxième question sur les appels à
projets concernant la pyrogazéification
plusieurs projets sont prêts
techniquement et économiquement mais
sont en attente de nouvelles concernant
le déploiement des contrats
d'expérimentation à ce jour aucun cahier
des charges n'est connu pouvez-vous nous
donner des éléments sur ce sujet
s'agissant des certificats de production
de biométhane une mesure que j'avais
portée dans le cadre de la loi climat et
résilience on est dans l'attente des
décrets d'application je souhaiterais
que vous puissiez nous apporter des
éléments sur le blocage regrettable de
ces décrets enfin ma dernière question
concerne l'impact de la flambée des prix
du gaz sur le bio GNV dont le prix a
doublé depuis un an dépassant de 30% le
prix du gasoil cette situation pénalise
fortement les entreprises et les
collectivités locales qui se sont
engagées dans la conversion de leur
flotte véhicule vers le biogenv donc
quels sont les mécanismes envisagés par
le gouvernement afin de garder une
compétitivité à ce secteur et soutenir
la filière de la méthanisation les
métiers en ont enfin ceux qui ont des
métalliseurs en ont bien besoin surtout
qu'ils aimeraient aussi également
bénéficier d'une consommation de leur
électricité puisque aujourd'hui comme
vous le savez l'autoconsommation est
restreint à l'électricité je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup Anne chant Larcher merci
madame la Présidente ma question
concerne l'esprit entre guillemets des
textes liés à l'énergie et leurs
conséquences pour les élus locaux
au premier rang desquels les mers nous
aurions besoin d'avoir vraiment des
exemples concrets sur votre état
d'esprit vous l'aurez compris le Sénat
ne sera pas tout à fait d'accord car
certaines dispositions du texte portent
particulièrement atteinte au pouvoir des
mers ou des intercommunalités en matière
d'urbanisme et les remontées du terrain
sont nombreuses les inquiétudes sont
nombreuses car non seulement leur avis
n'est pas aussi peu pris en
considération et le projet de loi
prévoit de remettre en cause les PLU et
les scottes madame la ministre tout
simplement je voudrais vous dire que
pour valser il faudrait être deux donc
on aura besoin de votre avis et et de
votre attention très très clair merci de
nous éclairer à ce sujet merci Anne
Jean-François oui la parole est à
Monsieur Frédéric marchand merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
concernant notre potentiel énergétique
en hydroélectricité compte tenu du
différent qui opposent la France à la
Commission européenne sur les
concessions et de l'absence à ce stade
d'accord permettant de lever la menace
de mise en concurrence les
développements les plus importants sur
les concessions hydroélectriques ne
peuvent avoir lieu pour autant certaines
mesures permettraient d'augmenter sans
attendre les capacités hydroélectriques
à court terme voire immédiatement sur
les installations existantes je pense à
deux particulièrement qui pourraient
être peut-être trouvé une écoute
favorable dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi c'est l'introduction de la
possibilité pour l'autorité
administrative d'autoriser
temporairement des augmentations de
puissance en cas de tension forte sur le
système électrique ou bien
l'introduction d'une possibilité de
limiter temporairement en cas de tension
forte sur le système électrique les
débits réservés restitués par les
installations hydroélectriques au cours
d'eau lorsque l'autoritan administrative
estimera que l'impact de cette mesure
n'a pas d'effet notable sur
l'environnement merci de me donner votre
avis sur ces suggestions
merci Franck montoget merci madame la
Présidente merci madame la ministre pour
votre présentation
à l'article 16 donc il est question de
la de la des zones en loi littorale
comment envisagez-vous de comptabiliser
l'artification l'artificialisation des
sols qui seront nécessaires pour
construire des lignes ou des postes de
transformation est-ce que
ce sujet ne mériterait pas que vous
envisagiez un compte état pour le zan
c'est à dire une prise en compte de la
de l'artificialisation au niveau
national
sur le le partage de la valeur
les les
rétrocessions aux consommateurs ou les
baisses de les baisses de tarif
finalement
seront comptabilisés je suppose au titre
de la de la CSPE
est-ce que est-ce que c'est le cas
on crée un précédent en faisant ça me
semble-t-il ça n'a jamais existé nulle
part et on entame d'une certaine manière
le principe de la préoccupation
tarifaire auquel on est quand même très
très attaché en particulier au Sénat
donc je voudrais savoir voilà
votre position là-dessus est entendu
qu'il y a aussi des situations
existantes pour lesquelles les communes
peuvent être affectées par les
installations et ne pas avoir reçu de
compensation ou les ou les ou les
consommateurs des des endroits concernés
voilà et ma dernière question
elle est généralement très simple vous
avez dit que vous souhaitiez une
démarche du terrain vers vers le haut si
j'ai bien compris sans employer des mots
anglais moi je pense qu'on y arrivera
pas s'il y a pas une déclinaison des
objectifs nationaux jusqu'au niveau des
territoires comment cette planification
territoriale vous allez la l'organiser
la réaliser pour qu'on soit au
rendez-vous des objectifs que l'on s'est
fixés parce que ça je ne le vois pas
concrètement alors c'est peut-être pas
dans cette loi qu'il faut qu'il faut en
parler mais si on réussit pas ça on y
arrivera pas ça je suis certain
merci
micro
voilà madame la ministre c'est un fait
que plus que la guerre à l'Ukraine et
ses conséquences sur notre pays en
matière d'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie la France comme d'autres pays
est en juinte par les scientifiques du
GIEC d'accélérer le pas pour sortir de
sa dépendance aux énergies fossiles vous
en tous bien d'accord là-dessus alors
certes nous avons progressé depuis 2005
en passant de 9% pour la part des ENR à
19% 2020 ce qui reste cependant
insuffisant et qui peut justifier
effectivement le remboursement le
renforcement de la production de LR
je voudrais d'abord vous dire que on
constate pour ce projet de loi que vous
n'avez pas ménagé vos efforts et vos
collaborateurs pour concerter l'ensemble
des groupes du Sénat et je considère
cette attitude particulièrement positive
néanmoins
néanmoins ben oui néanmoins au prétexte
que au prétexte que le cadre juridique
actuel les lois de protection de
l'environnement sont un frein pour
rattraper le retard le choix a donc été
fait de simplifier les procédures au
risque de réduire l'intervention des
élus et la consultation des citoyens
citoyens que vous comptez consulter par
la voie de la dématérialisation lorsque
l'on sait que précisément les
territoires concernés par ces projets
sont souvent aussi ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés du numérique
je souhaite insister sur la nécessité
d'impliquer les élus en amont et celles
des habitants car ils peuvent influer et
même influer favorablement sur
l'orientation des projets sur le terrain
il nous le disent ces élus il nous
disent qu'ils sont souvent inquiets de
l'entrisme de certains opérateurs qui
démarchent des propriétaires fonciers et
élaborent des projets sans toujours en
parler au maire alors qu'il demeure par
la suite à la commune de valider une
étude de faisabilité ne craignez-vous
pas madame la ministre que cette
procédure d'accélération intensive
s'avère contre-productive en
radicalisant les oppositions et en fait
et j'en aurai terminé le CNTE relève
certes la complexité de certaines
procédures administratives mais
soulignent aussi l'absence de
planification antérieure dont nous qui a
été évoqué d'ailleurs et l'insuffisance
des moyens humains et financiers de
l'État et des collectivités pour
instruire des projets qu'en pensez-vous
quelle mesure concrètes comptez-vous
prendre pour remédier à cette situation
merci beaucoup Serge babary
merci madame la présidente Madame le
Ministre j'aurai deux questions la
première concerne la compétence
indépendance des bureaux d'études
l'une des causes du retard dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
tu as recherché dans les insuffisances
des études réalisées dans le cadre des
évaluations des évaluations
environnementales se pose la question de
la compétence mais aussi de
l'indépendance des bureaux d'études
vis-à-vis des maîtres d'ouvrage qu'il
est mandatent et les rémunèrent
une réforme ambitieuse des bureaux
d'études et préconisée par le Conseil
Général de l'environnement et du
développement durable depuis octobre
2021 depuis le mois d'août dernier il
existe bien une charte d'engagement des
bureaux d'études dans le domaine
d'évaluation environnementales et cette
dernière repose sur un engagement
volontaire sans aucune force
contraignante pourquoi n'y a-t-il aucune
disposition sur ces points dans le
projet de loi qui nous est soumis et
plus particulièrement sur l'indépendance
des bureaux d'études à l'égard des
maîtres d'ouvrage deuxième question
concerne la localisation des producteurs
d'installation qu'elle est aujourd'hui
la part des éoliennes et panneaux
photovoltaïques produits respectivement
en France dans l'Union européenne et
orue et que prévoyez-vous pour accroître
la part de production française pour
répondre à la hausse programmée des
installations d'énergie renouvelables
quid par ailleurs des aides de la
rénovation et surtout au recyclage de
telles installations je vous remercie
merci Serge
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je souscris à l'idée et
développée par Didier mandeli que la
planification locale territoriale est un
des piliers de la propriétaire des
projets par les citoyens mais je
voudrais développer l'idée que le
deuxième pilier c'est sans doute le
partage de la valeur en tout cas pour
moi le partage de la valeur cependant
aujourd'hui on en est simplement à
ristourner en quelque sorte les
riverains à l'image de ceux qui se passe
sur le parc éolien de Bonneval situé en
heure et Loire qui propose de vendre aux
habitants riverains de cette
installation un tarif préférentiel qui
leur permet d'économiser sur leur
facture d'électricité par rapport à une
offre standard et je vous avoue que je
m'interroge sur ce type de dispositif
qui consiste quelque part à acheter
l'acceptation tacite des populations
concernées et ne leur permet pas de
devenir des acteurs à part entière d'un
projet qui s'impose sur leur territoire
et ne leur permet pas non plus à force
et à fortiori d'intégrer le capital de
tel projet donc je me posais la question
madame la ministre de savoir si ce
n'était pas une manière de contourner le
débat public et finalement de rater
l'objectif qui est le nôtre d'une
meilleure acceptabilité des projets et
d'une acculturation de nos citoyens par
rapport à ce changement énergétique et à
leur changement de paysage merci
merci beaucoup Daniel Laurent oui madame
la ministre madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président
vous auriez indiqué sur erreur de ma
part que vous souhaitiez favoriser
madame lapiniste l'implantation
d'éoliennes sur autour ou sur des sites
nucléaires
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus parce que
plus parce que c'est important et vous
savez que le
l'éolien est un certain traumatisme dans
certains territoires
concernant l'installation de centrale
photovoltaïques au sol dans les sites
dégradés des zones littorales je suis
très heureux qu'on avance qu'on ait
avancé sur la question que nous portons
Sénat depuis plusieurs années avec des
engagements des ministres successifs
puis des revirements soudains
quel temps perdu nous avons utilisé à ce
titre je remercie à nouveau initiative
de notre collègue Didier mandeli qui
suite à une proposition de loi visant à
permettre l'importation de panneaux
photovoltaïques sur les sites dégradés
et qui a été adopté en février dernier
l'article 9 du projet de loi précise que
la notion de friche renvoie à l'article
111 26 du code de l'urbanisme dans la
liste sera fixée par le par décret
pouvez-vous nous assurer que les sites
dégradés type ancienne carrière ou des
charges seront bien concernés car des
projets existent et sont toujours
bloqués dans l'attente d'une évolution
législative
entendez-vous madame la ministre revenir
sur le dispositif prévu en matière de
pouvoir d'urbanisme en effet
l'association des maires vous avez part
de sa totale opposition à toute atteinte
au pouvoir d'urbanisme notamment dans la
disposition qui permettrait à l'état
d'imposer que le PADD soit rendu
compatible des projets autorisés par
l'État sans compter que le dispositif
n'est pas articulé avec celui du zan et
le dernier question enfin sur le fond
vert de 1,5 milliards d'euros pour
accompagner la transition énergétique
des collectivités qui sera concernée
pour quel type de projet et se font
sera-t-il cumulable avec la DETR et
autres aides des collectivités je vous
remercie merci Daniel merci Madame
Pluchet puis après on va laisser
répondre à minuit pour faire une
deuxième on finira la deuxième série de
questions
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
le Ministre vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que depuis 2018 pour accélérer le
développement éolien on a
progressivement supprimé la voix des
élus locaux et réduit toujours plus les
possibilités de recours or dans ce
projet de loi je ne vois aucune
amélioration dans ce sens alors quelle
mesure concrète envisagez-vous pour
redonner enfin la voix aux élus locaux
et puis une petite deuxième question
concernant ce qu'on appelle le partage
des valeurs
vous n'êtes pas non plus madame la
ministre sans savoir que un parc éolien
nuit à l'attractivité d'un territoire
son développement touristique
la qualité de vie de ces administrés et
la valeur de leur foncier
alors je voulais savoir
si dans cette si cette redistribution
pardon annoncée elle va être à la
hauteur en fait du préjudice occasionné
dans nos territoires ruraux merci
madame la ministre
vous avez deux minutes
[Rires]
je vais choisir mes questions du coup
alors Monsieur gold je crois avoir
répondu de manière assez détaillée sur
le sujet de l'hydro de l'hydraulique à
la fois sur le nouveau cadre législatif
que souhaite donner la première ministre
à ce type d'installation et sur la
petite hydraulique et les décisions
récentes à la fois appel d'offres de la
creux qui a été lancé en 2022 qui doit
être lancé en 2023
pardon il est le texte réglementaire que
nous avons signé en juin 2022 donc je
complète pas ce propos
monsieur le sénateur minonville si jeudi
la proposition de loi sur le photo
l'agrovoltaïsme et voter je pense
qu'effectivement on pourra considérer
qu'elle peut servir de base
à une reprise dans le texte sur les
énergies renouvelables permettez
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une bonne
discussion en affaires écho donc
décidément
à chaque fois je le fais je sais pas
pourquoi
on va essayer de retrouver la voix voilà
donc si effectivement elle est adoptée à
peu près dans les formes où elle est
sortie de la Commission à faire écho je
pense que c'est vraiment une bonne base
pour
être réintégré dans le projet de loi
énergie renouvelable sur le zéro
artificiellement
artificialisation nette
le photovoltaïque qui est une question
qui est revenue à plusieurs reprises le
photovoltaïque ne comptera pas en côte
d'azane s'il respecte les conditions
prévues dans la loi climat et résilience
et l'éolien ne comptera pas en cotazane
non plus et c'est vrai avant et après
sur par contre je vous avais pas répondu
sur les raccordements parce que là je
pense que c'est potentiellement un sujet
parce qu'il y avait également le sujet
raccordement sur
[Musique]
monsieur le sénateur Kuiper le cadre de
la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie donc je le redis vous avez une
un débat public qui est ouverte sous les
guides de la Commission nationale du
débat public qui démarre en fin de
semaine qui s'achève début janvier qui
donne lieu ensuite à des travaux
techniques de mise en forme d'une
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
en parallèle en travail sur la stratégie
nationale bac carbone la révision de
cette stratégie et on travaille sur le
programme national d'adaptation au
changement climatique l'ensemble de ces
textes constitue la stratégie française
énergique climat et la partie
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
fait l'objet de la loi climat énergique
qui vous sera présenté
début fin du premier semestre au début
du deuxième semestre 2023 donc des
choses sont bien sont bien enchaînés et
mon objectif c'est d'avoir un minimum de
population avec les territoires pour en
fait essayer à bas bruit de construire
cette trajectoire ces trajectoire sur
les territoires sur un sur un modèle qui
serait de dire que
la
l'autonomie en matière énergétique et un
élément d'attractivité d'un territoire
et de regarder sur les territoires qui
veulent se prêter à l'exercice ce que ça
veut dire concrètement en termes de
programmation alors ça donnera pas
forcément lieu au vote de leur PC eat
mais au moins les travaux pourraient
être engagés on pourra vérifier qu'on
n'a pas des grossiers écart entre une
programmation nationale et une
déclinaison locale parce que vous savez
que en règle générale on l'articule
plutôt de manière séquentielle serielle
et qu'on peut arriver à des angles morts
à la fin donc ça c'est un enjeu et je
pense que fixer à chaque territoire un
objectif d'être capable de couvrir sa
consommation d'énergie voire de vouloir
devenir exportateur net ou vouloir
devenir
plateforme d'accueil pour des industries
supplémentaires fortement consommatrices
d'énergie ça peut être des objectifs de
territoires je vois certains territoires
qui se mettent déjà dans cette position
je pense que votre France que je connais
bien d'anticiper leur capacités de
production je pense que dans cet
exercice là il faut considérer que les
la partie nucléaire est un
est un collectif national distribué de
manière linéaire enfin voilà sur
l'ensemble du territoire et qui doit pas
être compté dans chacun des territoires
sinon ça serait pas juste et en tout cas
cet exercice là qui veut dire donc qu'on
se passe des énergies fossiles sera
assez dimensionnant
pour arriver à sortir une programmation
plus réelle et laissera probablement
apparaître des angles morts
je rappelle que les trois questions je
suis un petit peu longue mais je crois
que c'est important les trois questions
qui sont posées sur
la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie c'est comment adapter notre
consommation pour atteindre l'objectif
de neutralité carbone première question
deuxième question comment satisfaire nos
besoins en électricité et plus largement
en énergie parce qu'on a souvent eu un
focus très électrique vous avez raison
de mentionner qu'il y a toutes les
autres sujets tout en assurant la sortie
de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles et troisième question comment
planifier mettre en œuvre de financer
notre transition énergétique il me
semble que ça couvre bien les sujets qui
sont remontés dans les discussions que
nous avons sur la filière méthanisation
donc la PPE n'est pas repoussée comme
vous l'avez compris elle est dans le
calendrier
quelques semaines d'écart qui avait été
envisagées et
j'entends le souhait de la filière
méthanisation de relever son objectif
qui est un objectif de 10 à 20% du
biogaz gérer ça sera la résultante des
travaux
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est d'avoir une
indépendance énergétique j'ai tendance à
penser que tous les leviers activés pour
avoir une indépendance énergétique
seront à activer je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dépendants au
2/3 des énergies fossiles donc autant
dire que la marche a franchir et énorme
et se dire qu'on l'a franchi en 5 ans
paraît très ambitieux mais c'est bien de
faire cet exercice à titre pédagogique
parce qu'on pourra commencer à à
dessiner un scénario de réduction de
dépendance
monsieur
Chevrier sur les chevaliers sur les
assurances l'intégration dans
on sait qu'on a effectivement un
problème sur les assurances parce que
l'intégration des panneaux
photovoltaïques
ont pu
conduire à des problèmes d'étanchéité
qui sont observés à de nombreuses
reprises donc ça pose la question de la
qualité des travaux mais c'est pas
nouveau vous l'avez sur la rénovation
thermique vous l'avez sur un certain
nombre de sujets donc il est essentiel
de travailler avec les installateurs de
qualité de monter en compétences sur la
filière sujet de de compétences et nous
sommes également prêts à travailler avec
les assurances pour objectiver c'est ces
situations et je vous regarde pas c'est
pas bien je suis parti sur le sujet de
la Pyro gazéification
là aussi
on a alors je recherche mes notes parce
que c'est un sujet un peu technique
des études sont en cours pour envisager
un premier appel à projet qui devra en
toute état de cause d'être notifié
validé par l'Union européenne mais on
l'a bien sur notre feuille de route
puisque c'est un des une des
technologies qui peut émerger dans les
années qui viennent
cela s'inscrit là aussi dans les travaux
de révision de la stratégie française
énergie climat et de la planification
d'usage de notre source en biomasse pour
tout vous dire on a fait un premier
exercice de Run comme on appelle le
stratégie nationale bacarbone et quand
on regarde dans les détails on
s'aperçoit qu'on revend trois fois notre
biomasse donc ça ça va pas être possible
et effectivement il va falloir avoir un
travail où on n'imagine pas qu'on a une
espèce de
disponibilité de biomasse inexinglibles
et qu'on met au service de plein de
process énergétiques et une fois qu'on a
posé ça il faut regarder
par ordre de mérite comment on adresse
ces sujets là mais moi je suis très
favorable et vous savez qu'il y a des
lignes dans ça dans pour France 2030
aussi de soutenir les filières
industrielles et notamment la recherche
et de développement et l'innovation sur
les nouvelles les technologies
énergétiques parce que
qui aujourd'hui se qu'aujourd'hui on
connaît on peut faire l'hypothèse que
dans cinq ans ça sera différent et que
dans 10 ans ça sera très différent il
suffit de regarder où on en était il y a
5 ans sur l'hydrogène sur l'électrique
et sur certaines technologies
y compris en métal
sur les certificats de biométhane vous
avez parfaitement de production
biométhane vous avez parfaitement raison
de dire que le décret d'application doit
être publiée nous y travaillons il y a
un certain nombre de paramètres
trajectoires d'obligation plus réelle
niveau de pénalité à définir mais je
peux vous dire que j'ai transmis premier
projet en concertation pour validation
donc on avance sur ces sujets là et je
prends le point pour moi
sur Madame chamarchais les documents
d'urbanisme je crois que j'ai déjà
répondu à la question en réponse au
rapporteur de manière assez claire sur
monsieur marchand l'autorisation
temporaire
[Musique]
si j'ai été clair c'est-à-dire j'ai je
peux le redire c'est donc de mémoire le
troisième alinéa de l'article 3 qui fait
débat j'en ai discuté avec le président
de l'AMF et la suggestion que je faisais
c'était de rendre ce pouvoir à
l'autorité qui est en charge du document
d'urbanisme pour lui permettre de
déroger elle-même par vote à ce document
d'urbanisme pour ne pas avoir à faire
tout le toute la mise à toute
l'adaptation et c'est une demande qui
nous remonte des élus locaux
c'est-à-dire de dire il y a des énergies
enfin il y a des projets qui sont
compatibles en réalité avec notre schéma
mais il y a des choses dans nos
documents dans urbanisme qui n'ont pas
été mises à jour et si on reprend si on
refait tous les documents d'urbanisme
pour le projet en question alors qu'il
est à la marge incompatible on est parti
pour 18 mois et c'est pas notre objectif
donc je pense que si on le rend dans ce
sens là on est à mon avis on rend le
pouvoir
aux collectivités locales et on leur
épargne l'effet tunnels ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas qu'elle remette jamais à
jour leurs documents d'urbanisme soyons
clairs mais
je pense qu'elles vont devoir de toute
façon le faire mais ça leur permet de
pouvoir agir le temps de faire ce
travail dont on sait qu'il est
enfin qui prend du temps monsieur le
sénateur marchant
sur l'hydro et les autorisations
temporaires d'augmentation de puissance
en cas de tension forte sur le système
électrique vous savez que le contrat du
barrage de Sacha m'ont permet
d'accroître la production dans une
certaine mesure on sera vigilant sur la
salinité on expertise une augmentation
de puissance de barrage de Kems pour
l'hiver prochain et vous avez pu voir
passer un amendement qui est proposé
dans le projet de loi de finances 23
pour revoir le cadre des redevances qui
brident les augmentations puissances
d'installation déjà existantes mais dans
notre analyse ça relève d'un pays
sur tout
monsieur montoget donc sur les ânes vous
avez posé une question spécifique sur
les raccordements je vous reviens j'ai
pas la réponse voilà sur sur la
péréquation
tarifaire on ne change pas le niveau du
TRV on ne change pas le niveau du turc
on prévoit une réduction forfaitaire et
non pas une réduction proratale la
consommation donc qui nous semble que ça
ne change rien la péréquation tarifaire
néanmoins encore une fois moi je dis mon
ouverture pour travailler sur cet
article
et donc ça on vous revient sur sur cette
question c'est défini ensuite par en
réglementaire
sur tac tac tac peréquation la
déclinaison des objectifs au niveau
territorial
alors cette déclinaison elle est prévue
théoriquement dans la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie puisque vous avez
des compétences
à la fois des stradettes et des pceat
je pense que c'est des c'est des sujets
qui ont une vocation est travaillé dans
la loi dans la programmation plus réelle
de l'énergie là encore moi j'entends une
demande de platineification un petit peu
anticipée c'est un point dont on peut
effectivement discuter mais la logique
c'est que la somme des pcats égale la
programmation plyonnelle de l'énergie et
pareil sur l'estradettes
entre cette logique de jardin la
française et la réalité auquel on
arrivera il y aura probablement des
choses qui déborderont à droite à gauche
mais je pense que c'est nécessaire de
faire l'exercice et c'est pour ça que je
mentionner l'idée de faire un exercice à
blanc avec des collectivités locales qui
sont
qui seraient volontaires
en parallèle de l'exercice pleurait
enfin PPE que nous sommes en train de
mener c'est le sens du travail que nous
menons avec Christophe Béchu sur la
planification écologique en disant ça ne
vaut que si la somme de ce qu'on fait en
haut est égal à ce qui est fait sur le
terrain voilà d'où la contractualisation
d'une Conseil national de la refondation
madame varias risque de diminuer la
consultation des élus avec la
consultation numérique vous savez que
c'est au fond une mise en adéquation de
ce qui existe déjà sur des projets de
plus grande taille et qui avait été fait
dans la loi accélération il
simplification de l'action publique
sur la question
de l'entrisme des porteurs de projets
parce que c'est un point qui n'est pas
infondé en tout cas on l'entend
[Musique]
bon on sait la programmation et le fait
d'avoir des pceat qui quelque part
prévoit des zones favorables à l'accueil
d'énergie renouvelables peut donner lieu
en fait à des logiques comme on l'a fait
sur les sites industriels d'avoir des
sites clés en main qui quelque part
oriente les porteurs de projets vers ces
sites je pense que c'est ça la bonne la
bonne direction et de publier ces sites
histoire d'éviter l'effet j'appelle tous
les propriétaires fonciers du
appartements de tel endroit en regardant
les endroits où le foncier est pas cher
possible pousser mes projets qui
potentiellement une pratique qu'on voit
et qui pose aussi d'ailleurs un problème
un problème d'inégalité territoriale
puisque ce sont les territoires
officiels moins chers donc souvent les
plus pauvres qui se retrouvent à être
confronté enfin à l'accueil de plus en
plus de projets donc moi je ne pense pas
qu'accueillir des énergies renouvelables
ce soit un poids je pense que c'est un
atout pour le territoire mais il y a une
question quand même d'équilibre si vous
portez tous les projets à un moment ça
finit par se voir et créer de
la perte de confiance sur les bureaux
d'études ils doivent être déjà
indépendants à la réglementation de
prévois les organismes doit être
certifiés pour les missions qui relèvent
d'une obligation réglementaire et si
toutefois des cas de manquements
d'indépendance sont identifiés en
contradiction avec la réglementation la
certification peut être retirée au
bureau d'études ça c'est l'état de la
loi aujourd'hui où je pense que l'enjeu
c'est qu'elle soit bien appliquée et
donc les signalements se fassent pour
qu'on puisse éviter ce genre de
situation
problématique monsieur barbarie sur
l'insuffisance des pardon j'ai
anticipé la question
sur
la localisation des équipements c'est un
point qui est très important vous savez
que sur le photovoltaïque on n'a pas
d'industrie solide en France de
production de panneaux photovoltaïques
que plus de 80% des panneaux
photovoltaïques sont fabriqués à
l'étranger pour ne pas dire en Chine que
nous travaillons au niveau européen à
intégrer des notions de contenu carbone
des panneaux pour créer une incitation à
produire en Europe et à produire en
France mais que nous avons aussi des
enjeux de compétitivité sur sur ce type
de filière moi j'ai travaillé sur un
certain nombre de projets d'installation
de de
[Musique]
ça fonctionne aujourd'hui je veux dire
l'empreinte française est importante il
y a des usines à Saint-Nazaire à
Cherbourg au Havre sur l'éolien
terrestre l'empreinte est un peu plus
resserrée mais on a quelques éléments
quelques composants sur le
photovoltaïque c'est je l'ai dit loin
d'être formidable sur la géothermie on a
les briques qui existent et à nous les
assembler d'en faire une filière
puissante il y a sur ces sujets là des
crédits dans le plan France 2030
sur l'aide à la rénovation et le
recyclage de ces installations je pense
que ça doit faire partie des cahiers des
charges pour une bonne et simple raison
c'est que ça permet aussi de répondre à
la question précédente
d'augmenter la valeur locale des projets
madame Philippe filleul vous avez une
inquiétude sur la façon d'associer donc
on revient toujours sur certains article
donc à la fois tout le monde est
d'accord sur l'objectif mais il n'y a
pas un enthousiasme
débordant par rapport à la manière dont
il est rédigé si je résume ce que
j'entends
pas d'intégration capital ça peut être
un sujet dont on peut discuter ça existe
au Danemark ça existe en Allemagne je
pense qu'il faut pas trop verrouiller
non plus le sujet sinon on va partir
effectivement dans une complexification
mais peut-être ouvrir la possibilité
j'ai cru entendre ici là que question
était envisagée je pense pas que ce soit
incontournement du débat public par
contre
et je le redis pour moi une installation
d'énergie renouvelable ce n'est pas un
poids pour le territoire ça doit être
vécu comme un élément d'attractivité
c'est le fait d'avoir des installations
qui arrivent sans préavis parfois un peu
masqué
qui qui pose un problème je pense que
c'est bien faire la différence entre les
deux Monsieur Laurent non j'ai pas
l'intention pas particulièrement
d'installer des éoliennes en proximité
d'installation nucléaires
voilà ça peut être possible ça peut ne
pas être possible en fait j'en sais rien
ça dépend des territoires et c'est là où
la planification fait du sens oui je
l'ai indiqué dans mon propos introductif
les anciennes carrières et les décharges
sont bien intégrées dans l'article 9
j'ai répondu sur le dispositif pouvoir
d'urbanisme et sur le fond vert je
renverrai aux discussions qui sont à
venir sur le projet loi de finance pour
finir en fait monsieur
[Musique]
coucher madame Pluchet pardon
la voix aux élus les cours j'ai
également répondu sur cette question
notamment sur les documents d'urbanisme
et sur la planification
sur le partage de la valeur mais je
crois qu'on revient sur la même question
à nouveau donc pas compter voilà
mais chers vous êtes encore très
nombreux donc je vous demande vraiment
d'être
court dans vos questions et s'il vous
plaît de pas reposer des questions qui
ont déjà été posées auxquelles la
ministre a déjà répondu et je dis juste
à mes collègues de la commission des
affaires économiques de ne pas partir
quand oubliez pas que nous avons une
commission ensuite sur voilà sur le
photovoltaïque Henri Cabanel pardon
merci madame la Présidente je vais
évoquer la grille voltaïque qui est
effectivement une façon de produire de
l'énergie renouvelable tout en
garantissant le respect de la terre
nourricière donc d'avoir de maintenir
une une agriculture à faire en tout cas
c'est ce que nous souhaitons nous
souhaitons tous et je vous remercie de
ce que vous venez d'annoncer de
l'inclure éventuellement dans votre
projet de loi
s'il n'y a pas un cadre plus strict à
mon sens que
le
colmer un aval la PPL que nous aurons à
débattre demain il y aura certainement
des dérives il est souhaitable que il
n'est pas souhaitable que des porteurs
de projets profitent seuls d'un foncier
à bas coût pour leur business et je
reviens à nouveau sur le partage de la
valeur qui doit se faire entre les
territoires les propriétaires fonciers
éventuellement les agriculteurs quand
ils ne sont pas propriétaires fonciers
donc Madame la Ministre comment
voyez-vous ce partage de la valeur
sachant que
ces investissements ont un coût
important et que ni les propriétaires
fonciers ni les agriculteurs ne pourront
se le permettre puisqu'il faut compter à
peu près un million par mégawatt
j'ai visité une entreprise qui est en
train de mettre un projet à
grivevoltaïque sur un territoire sur 37
hectares et il a décidé de donner le
loyer
aux propriétaires fonciers et de 2000
euros par an et à l'agriculteur de 500
euros par an sur des terres à peu
potentiel agronomique qui va à peu près
5000 euros donc la question pour moi
c'est comment allons-nous éviter la
spéculation sur le prix du foncier
voilà
et la parole est à Daniel
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
c'est sur les encouragements et avec le
concours de votre prédécesseur madame
barbara Pompili que Madame le préfet de
Eloi c'était porté volontaire pour
lancer un travail de concertation sur
l'implantation des sites de production
d'énergie renouvelable et éoliennes
méthaniseur photovoltaïque sur tout le
département s'agissant de l'éolien dans
un premier temps cela aboutit à une
cartographie un schéma d'implantation
recommandé excluant également les
secteurs jugés impossible à retenir
cette démarche a été saluée car elle
s'est voulu apaisante et depuis un an un
comité départemental des énergies se
réunit pour émettre des avis sur tous
les projets instruits avec les porteurs
de projets les élus et les représentants
de toutes les collectivités les
associations cela me conduit madame la
ministre a considéré que la création
d'un tel schéma est plutôt une idée
intéressante nous travaillons
actuellement l'étendre sur une mise en
place pour les méthaniseurs qui est un
véritable sujet qui enflamme nos
territoires
alors j'ai une question est-ce que vous
avez ou non l'intention de conforter
cette méthode
expérimentale qui en est Loire est
plutôt positive et la deuxième c'est
quel est votre position s'agissant des
avis que nous rendons au sein de ce
comité au regard de leur caractère
consultatif hélas merci
merci Daniel Sylviane Noël merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre je
souhaiterais tout d'abord revenir sur
vos propos concernant les concessions
hydroélectriques vous savez qu'une forte
pression est exercée par les instances
européennes sur la France depuis
plusieurs années pour l'ouverture à la
concurrence de ces concessions
hydroélectriques majoritairement gérée
par EDF actuellement cette ouverture à
la concurrence par l'eau va
inévitablement affaiblir et morceler le
secteur conduisant à une multiplication
d'acteurs tournés vers la seule
recherche de rentabilité ce qui ne
manquera pas de mettre en danger notre
potentiel hydroélectrique ma question
est simple je voudrais savoir si la
France va s'opposer à cette ouverture à
la concurrence comme l'ont fait bon
nombre de voisins européens par ailleurs
je souhaitais vous faire part des villes
inquiétudes suscitées par l'adoption du
décret 2022
452 du 30 mars dernier ce décret prévoit
parmi ces dispositions d'interdire
l'utilisation sur le domaine public en
extérieur des systèmes de chauffage et
climatisation pour tous les occupants du
domaine public à compter du 31 mars 2022
cette mesure suscite l'incompréhension
et l'inquiétude de nombreux commerçants
non sédentaires à l'approche de l'hiver
particulièrement dans des territoires
comme le mien ou la rigueur du climat
nous concerne environ 6 mois de l'année
il ne s'agit pas là d'une question de
confort ces derniers ont un besoin vital
de ces appareils pour exercer leur
activité protéger leurs denrées donc ma
question est simple envisagez-vous de
revenir sur ce décret pour le moins
déconnecter de la réalité des
territoires je vous remercie
madame Préville merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre alors je
vais vous reparler des énergies
renouvelables qui doivent se développer
mais pour lesquels nous avons du retard
et sur le fait qu'il s'agit bien d'une
politique nationale je suis ici voilà et
qui devrait être un service en quelque
sorte publique n'est-ce pas c'est
important en grande partie privée qui se
mette en place et si je vous parle de
cela c'est parce que l'entrisme qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure est une
réalité dans mon département le lot des
projets photovoltaïques se mettent en
place on les agriculteurs sont des
marchés sans que les élus ne soient au
courant on leur promet des revenus et là
je alors dans mon département 6500 euros
l'hectare quand on connaît évidemment
les revenus modestes des agriculteurs
ben on se doute bien que c'est un se
sont des revenus alléchant voilà qui va
provoquer un développement désordonné
anarchique et qui déjà provoque des
levées de boucliers avec les qui
découvrent après coup les projets et qui
génère de l'inacceptabilité de la part
des riverains bien sûr donc dans cette
idée là quelle place
pourrait être faite au projet qui serait
bien plus vertueux participatif qui
associerait les collectivités
territoriales les citoyens concernés
dans la proximité par ces projets là et
comme cela déjà été évoqué qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens d'engager c'est ces
financements là ne faudrait-il pas
mettre peut-être des obligations pour
ces petits projets territoriaux de
d'impliquer forcément les collectivités
et les citoyens pour embarquer tout le
monde et que tout puisse bien se passer
et puis j'avais une autre question toute
petite question sur les les économies
qu'on doit faire
d'électricité sur les possibilités qu'on
peut avoir de développer par exemple des
chauffe-eau solaire qui sont
régulièrement absent de toutes les
réflexions qu'on peut avoir et qui sont
des dispositifs excellents est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas prévoir peut-être de des
obligations dans les futurs
constructions d'avoir ces dispositifs là
parce que je pour moi je trouve que ce
on aurait de grands avancés sur le sujet
merci beaucoup Martine Berthet merci
madame la Présidente j'ai deux questions
mais je vais faire très vite madame la
ministre des Entreprises m'ont
interpellé qui voient leur contrat avec
EDF se terminer au 30 novembre 2022 elle
se retrouve dans l'obligation
d'enseigner un nouveau trévite le coût
proposé de 730 euros legawh soit pour
2023 une charge qui passera pour elle de
2 millions et demi à 17 millions pour
quand la décorrélation en France du prix
de l'électricité
de celui du gaz c'est ma première
question la deuxième donc la Savoie est
un des départements les plus concernés
par les hypers électro-intensifs ils ont
l'électricité comme matière première et
paradoxalement il s'était installé là en
toute proximité d'une hydroélectricité
peu cher et madame la ministre qui ne
venait pas de l'autre bout du monde
leur contrat long terme arrive au bout
sauf quelques rares exceptions il y a
urgence dès janvier les possibilités de
nouveaux contrats qui figurent dans le
projet de loi nouveau contrats long
terme seront-elles déjà en place et
sinon quelle solution en attendant car
les productions commencent à s'arrêter
le rapport Philippe darmaillian donc a
émis des propositions mais il n'a pas
été édité pourquoi va-t-il l'être il
serait intéressant que nous puissions le
consulter et puis j'ai un dernier point
en lien avec ma collègue et la dernière
question qui vient d'être posée sur la
formation il est très important
effectivement d'aller sur la formation
de nos artisans sur les nouvelles
technologies je pense à l'inès
l'Institut national de l'énergie solaire
qui a mis en place un plateau de
formation que l'on ait inauguré
dernièrement je pense qu'il faut que cet
exemple soit développé un peu partout en
France Merci Merci la parole est à
Jean-Michel Houlgate merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre donc en
amont de cette loi d'accélération le
Conseil Général de l'environnement du
développement durable c'est
gedd qui dépend de votre ministère donc
à rédiger un rapport sur la
modernisation de la participation du
public et des procédures
environnementales de même le Conseil
économique social et environnemental à
lui produit un avis sur l'acceptabilité
des nouvelles infrastructures de
transition énergétique qui s'appelle
transition rubis ou transition choisie
d'un comme un accord ces travaux
mentionnent qu'une des conditions
facilitant l'acceptabilité ou plutôt
l'appropriation des projets passent par
une concertation systématique le plus en
amont possible des projets et
Concertation également continue tout au
long du déroulement des procédures sous
l'égide de garant de commissaire
enquêteurs et même parfois de médiateurs
le CGED dit notamment rendre
systématique l'engagement de la
concertation des stades de l'intention
du maître d'ouvrage il dit nommer un
garant pour chaque projet etc etc de
même je reprendrai parce que le temps
est extrêmement compté même même avis
pour pour le Conseil économique social
et environnemental alors personnellement
je vois pas dans le texte de loi des
avancées sur justement une extension le
plus en amont possible de de cette
concertation donc vous prêt à réintégrer
ces recommandations et puis deuxièmement
il est évident que que le gouvernement
est prêt enfin le pardon le bon
déroulement d'une procédure est lié à
des moyens et est-ce que les moyens de
l'État sont adaptés aux enjeux de la
transition écologique et puis s'il me
reste vraiment quelques secondes dans
l'article 11 sur les parcs de
stationnement pourquoi avoir introduit
cette obligation de végétalisation
permettant la perméabilité et
l'infiltration des eaux pluviales
merci beaucoup Rémi Cardon s'il vous
plaît merci de par poser les questions
déjà posées oui mais tu seras là
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre votre projet de loi comporte un
volet relatif au partage de la valeur
vous n'êtes pas censé savoir que j'ai
déposé il y a peu une proposition de loi
visant à un développement de l'éolien
terrestre respectueux des territoires et
des habitants qui proposaient justement
notamment une modification de la
répartition de l'ifère l'actuelle
répartition est souvent perçue comme
injuste et provoque des jalousies voire
des recours à cause justement d'une
partage de la valeur inadaptée du coup
la question est simple madame la
ministre quelle est votre position sur
l'opportunité d'une nouvelle répartition
de l'ifère qui serait plus favorable
justement aux communes les plus
impactées par ces projets je vous
remercie
il la parole est à Monsieur gilet je
vous remercie monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre pour prolonger
justement un questionnement la vie du
Conseil d'État était ses critique
notamment dans l'approche concernant la
mobilisation des moyens humains pour
améliorer toutes les procédures et les
instructions alors très directement
allez-vous intervenir au niveau du PLF
pour renforcer les moyens de
l'administration sur ce sujet là
puisqu'il a été pointé que les moyens
étaient insuffisants on note également
un effet accélérateur qui est
intéressant c'est le fait que les
porteurs de projets notamment sur des
projets de taille moyenne puissent
bénéficier d'une ingénierie
d'accompagnement qui leur permet
d'instruire leur projet leur dossiers
dans les meilleures conditions avez-vous
envisagé également un accompagnement
particulier en amont sur ce sujet enfin
le dernier point concernant les raisons
impératives d'intérêt public majeur
elles inquiète un peu sur le sujet
notamment sur la nature des projets qui
rentreront dans le champ de cet article
car les conditions
vous allez devoir reprendre seront
définis par décret est-ce qu'on pourrait
nous en définir déjà un peu le périmètre
je vous remercie
merci
oui merci Madame la prison madame la
ministre
je redis que c'est complexe pour nous en
parle mon père d'avoir une vision
globale en continuant en saucissonnant
les textes ou parler de l'hydro la
première ministre nous a dit la semaine
dernière dans l'hémicycle qui aurait un
texte sur Livron puis vous nous dites
que ça se fera dans le cadre de la
réalité utilisation de EDF dont nous on
pourra pas parler parce que ça sera ben
si on n'aura pas un projet de loi pour
être attiser EDF sauf si nous nous dit
que le contraire aujourd'hui ce en quoi
j'en serais ravi et je pense que je
serai pas le seul dans cette salle
et donc il y aura une quasi régie sur
les barrages bon bref vous voyez que
c'est un peu complexe parce que
l'électricité c'est l'aménagement du
territoire c'est le partage de la valeur
moi je pense que je serai pas sur du
tout sur la même ligne que mes collègues
parce que je pense que si on met le
doigt dans le partage de la valeur
demain
ben non mais c'est pas ça si si on peut
partager la valeur de la richesse créée
par les travailleurs par le salaire ça
oui mais si vous mettez le doigt et le
faut mais si vous mettez le doigt là
dedans chaque fois qu'il y aura un grand
projet faudra partager la valeur et il y
a une question c'est la péricquation
tarifaire et il y aura des territoires
qui en auront pas et il y aura des
territoires il y en aura plein et c'est
la question individuelle ou collective
bon bref donc une question précise sur
l'article 18 parce que celui-là il n'a
pas été il n'a pas été posé sur les PPA
donc en direct des entreprises vont
pouvoir lier des contrats à long terme
avec des énergéticiens des producteurs
là on met un doigt de plus dans la
libéralisation du secteur ce qui nous
conduit dans la situation dans laquelle
on est bah si par exemple ce qu'on m'a
donné cet exemple là on m'a dit mais par
exemple voyez la Nouvelle-Calédonie
totale pourra s'occuper de d'alimenter
les circuits courts et notamment les
projets dominent de nickel et puis total
nous rend un partenariat en direct avec
un producteur sur les très long terme
sortira donc du système sortira du
système puisqu'il aura en direct un
producteur directement à l'entreprise et
tout le reste et je pense que mettre le
doigt dedans
mais je sais que c'est déjà fait avec
les contractions tout seul je connais
tout ça mais mettre accélérer tout ça va
faire que dans la crise actuelle que
l'on vit des grandes entreprises vont
vouloir sortir complètement du système
du marché et aussi du système d'EDF est
nouer en direct des partenariats
auxquels l'État va subventionner pour
qu'il passe eux-mêmes des contrats long
terme je vous le dis avec notre groupe
on sera plutôt opposé sur cet article 18
comme il n'avait pas été évoqué je
posais cette question voilà
ici la parole est à Madame
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre pouvez-vous nous préciser les
propositions pour le déploiement des ENR
sur les zones non interconnectées du
Ponant Corse outre-mer qui sont
largement en retard sur les objectifs
d'autonomie à horizon 2030 et les
ennemis conservent effectivement un taux
très important de dépendance aux
énergies importées
merci Amel Amel gacer
madame la ministre madame monsieur les
présidents évidemment comme mes
collègues je partage pleinement
l'ambition donc de développer les
énergies renouvelables mais je souhaite
mettre le doigt sur un des obstacles à
la mise en oeuvre de la transition
énergétique pas assez évoqué à mon sens
ou brièvement celui des moyens alloués
au service de l'État seront en charge de
l'instruction des projets de
développement énergétique pour accélérer
délai vous avez évoqué à plusieurs
pistes dont celle du Foncia libéré une
meilleure concertation et acceptabilité
de la population mais pas celle des
moyens humains de l'État et des
collectivités madame la ministre la
question est-elle soulevée si oui je
l'espère quel moyen supplémentaires
envisagez-vous sachant que vous avez
d'ores et déjà demandé ou préfet d'aller
plus vite merci
déjà posé de la question quels sont les
moyens humains et notamment la DGC que
vous pourrez obtenir pour réussir cette
nouvelle politique de transition
énergétique merci madame la ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
remercier madame la ministre pour son
introduction pour dire clairement que
sans un développement rapide de l'éolien
terrestre et maritime nous ne passerons
pas et que donc bien évidemment notre
responsabilité ça va être d'accompagner
ce développement rapide sinon c'est
l'économie française qui sera en grande
difficulté
donc vous l'avez dit Madame le Ministre
on commence par le Sénat parce que la
question des territoires est au cœur et
finalement c'est une loi ou les
territoires sont assez peu présents donc
plusieurs questions assez précises
d'abord sur les fameux pipiers sur les
contrats long terme aujourd'hui c'est
pas la même question que mon collègue
Fabien gay c'est plutôt centré sur les
entreprises et il y a une forte demande
c'était le cas il y a une heure dans le
Congrès d'amorce pour l'ouvrir plus
clairement aux collectivités
territoriales que la manière dont c'est
écrit dans la loi donc est-ce que vous
pouvez me confirmer qu'on va réécrire
l'article pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté et ouvrir largement aux
collectivités territoriales je pas le
résultat je pense que c'est une question
attendue et derrière je pense la
question de notre collègue moto j'ai été
assez clair sur le fait de dire il faut
aller vers une planification
effectivement passons notamment par les
pcaet qui dans la loi effectivement j'ai
bien aimé votre vision du jardin à la
française mais on en est un peu loin
mais dans la loi effectivement
normalement les PCET sont adossés sur
les objectifs de la France ce qui veut
dire est-ce que vous pouvez rediscuter
avec vos collègues de Bercy où le
Secrétariat à la planification pour dire
parce que ça c'est une demande unanime
votée par le Sénat plusieurs fois de
dire puisque là il y a 2 milliards sur
la table dans le fond vert que si vous
voulez que les collectivités les
territoires développent effectivement
les projets de renouvelables et
l'efficacité et la sobriété énergétique
il leur faut du financement en
fonctionnement et en une générique et
pas seulement en investissement on le
dit tous les ans en loi de finance donc
c'est l'occasion
euh de repasser le message parce que
c'est un point tout à fait clé si on
veut atteindre les objectifs que vous
avez dernier point sur l'acceptabilité
il y a peut-être une piste parce qu'on
est tous conscients qu'on a des
difficultés d'acceptabilité mais qui ne
doivent pas être dilatoires est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas passer par des amis
de collectivités qui veulent développer
clairement l'éolien ou le photovoltaïque
et qui à partir du moment où il y a une
démarche par la mi on le dernier mot sur
le projet le plus adapté au territoire
donc pas de manœuvre dinatoire mais
peut-être permettre aux territoire qui
veulent développer l'éolien ou le
photovoltaïque de de passer par un appel
à manifestation d'intérêt qui éviterait
des pratiques de cow-boy qui
effectivement existent sur certains
territoires
merci Anne Catherine Loisier enfin merci
madame la Présidente moi je voudrais
revenir rapidement sur votre
introduction madame la ministre et votre
argumentation ce que vous avez commencé
en disant il était nécessaire de palier
à la faible disponibilité du parc
nucléaire donc pour mieux sécuriser les
je reprends vos propos pour mieux
sécuriser les approvisionnements
ce qui me ce qui m'interroge dans dans
cette manière d'aborder le sujet c'est
que on choisit de privilégier les EnR
non pilotables c'est-à-dire celles qui
seront les moins à même finalement de
répondre à des besoins de sécurisation
des approvisionnements et on sait
aujourd'hui que ces NR non pilotables
sont soumises à des aléas je pense au
turpitude de nos voisins allemands qui
ont connu une baisse de 40% de la
production éolienne l'année dernière
donc ma question c'est comment
pensez-vous soutenir et accélérer le
déploiement des ENR pilotables qui vont
vraiment nous aider à passer les
périodes de crise et qui seront
activables quand nous en aurons besoin
Marsa de Sidrac la parole merci
président madame la présidente madame la
ministre je ne reviendrai pas sur un
certain nombre de questions qui ont
porté sur ce texte qui est
essentiellement technique
toutefois je souhaitais vous interroger
sur deux points que je n'ai pas vu dans
le texte un qui est un petit peu dans la
première question qui est un peu dans la
continuité de celle qui vient de vous
être posée par ma collègue
Anne-Catherine Loisier qui concerne en
fait la vulnérabilité de ces futurs
éoliennes que l'on envisage de déployer
et que nous sommes nombreux bien
évidemment à partager enfin nous sommes
nombreux à partager les objectifs
annoncés je pense à la vulnérabilité
évidemment climatique mais aussi un peu
plus largement de la vulnérabilité en
réalité de sécurité simplement on sait
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un monde
où il existe beaucoup de conflits dans
différents domaines avec des paires de
plus en plus élevés et puis des durées
de plus en plus longues donc je
souhaitais que vous nous rassuriez sur
ce point-là quelles sont les mesures en
réalité que peut-être vous avez envisagé
pour pallier à ce genre de questions et
ma deuxième question concerne très
simplement
enfin j'aurais aimé avoir un éclairage
sur le démantèlement futur de ses
éoliennes puisque vous avez évoqué dans
vos propos liminaires que nous arrivons
à un parc aujourd'hui d'une quarantaine
d'années donc on va se poser la question
déjà de ce parc là mais dans le futur
envisagez-vous en réalité de mettre en
place une filière de démantèlement de
d'économie circulaire sur le volet des
éoliennes que l'on va déployer en masse
merci
merci Marie-Noël linman
je reprends la question sur les moyens
de l'État que je crois tout à fait
essentiel parce que quand on regarde le
déroulement le nombre de journées ou de
mois perdu par retard et considérable
alors je ne me contente pas de la
question disant allez-vous obtenir les
moyens la question qui se pose c'est
combien faut-il de fonctionnaires est
allé dans le temps et dans quel type de
poste pour que les blocages qu'on
connaît sur le terrain puissent être
levés avec certitude parce que mon
expérience des gens ancienne de
fonctionnement de l'État me fait penser
qu'on dit toujours la consultation c'est
long et puis le reste on l'oublie donc
êtes-vous en mesure de nous faire ou en
tout cas assez rapidement un calcul des
besoins de renforcement des services de
l'État nous permettant de les programmer
dans les lois budgétaires le deuxième
c'est la filière photovoltaïque vous
avez juste ce titre dit qu'elle était
enfin quand je dis filière ces
productions des panneaux qu'elle était
dans une mauvaise état enfin en tout cas
pas suffisante en France je vous ai
trouvé résigné et je comprends que vous
que la situation soit pas facile
néanmoins il nous faut du volontarisme
je crois d'ailleurs que les Français
accepteront mieux toute une série de
d'efforts faits pour les élèves si deux
surcroît elle contribue au développement
économique et industriels français donc
je vous pose la question la France ne
doit-elle pas demander à l'Union
européenne dérogation pour les aides
d'État concernant le soutien à la
filière photovoltaïque puisque
aujourd'hui nous sommes d'une hyper
vulgérabilité avec la Chine deuxièmement
avez-vous lancé un plan de recherche
recherche et recherche développement sur
les nouvelles méthodes
en général photovoltaïque en particulier
permettant de développer et de faire
muter nos fil et troisièmement comment
contraindre la puissance publique la
commande publique a privilégier toujours
le made in France comment expliquer
qu'EDF et liquider Photowatt pour
acheter des panneaux chinois
moi je vais vous poser une question très
vite c'est celle de Jean-Pierre Moga qui
est absent parce qu'il est rapporteur du
budgétaire sur la recherche mais ces
questions déjà étaient un petit peu
évoquées c'est est-ce que on pourra
intégrer la PPL de définissant la
grivevoltaïsme de qui passera demain
dans le projet
accélération des énergies et ça vous a
été posé aussi et c'est un peu plus
compliqué et sur la sur le problème lié
à la question du fermage voilà c'est
rapide
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre dans la continuité des
questions de certaines de nos collègues
je voudrais revenir sur nos craintes
quant à la volonté assumée par l'état de
passer en force sans faire grand cas ni
de la vie des élus locaux ni de la
population je n'en veux que pour preuve
une instruction que vous avez signé avec
vos collègues ministres de l'Intérieur
et ministre de l'Industrie le 16
septembre dernier à destination des
préfets qui traite à la fois des
perspectives de délestage l'hiver
prochain et de l'implantation des
installations d'énergie renouvelables
concernant l'accélération du
développement des projets d'énergie
renouvelable dans cette instruction il
est exigé des préfets qu'il fasse en
sorte qu'aucune instruction n'excède 24
mois il leur est demandé de créer une
adhésion locale autour des projets
notamment des collectivités locales cela
pose la question l'adhésion locale ne se
décrète pas et toujours dans cette même
instruction que vous avez signé le 16
septembre
il est clairement demandé au préfet de
serrer la vis vis-à-vis des mers qui ont
prononcé dans leur plu des interdictions
générales et absolues d'implantation de
projets renouvelable normalement de
parcs éolien c'est document d'urbanisme
devront faire l'objet d'un contrôle de
l'égalité attentif ce qui signifie pour
parler clairement que les préfets sont
appelés à chercher à tout prix la faille
qui pourrait permettre de casser ces
documents alors si on comprend que vous
vouliez faire preuve de volontarisme sur
ces sujets on peut quand même être
inquiet pourquoi avoir pris une telle
instruction avant même le débat sur le
projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables
merci Dominique Jean-François t'as pas
d'autres intervenants
et ensuite pour terminer Yves Boulou
madame la prévienne-dante madame la
ministre
cela concerne les projets de petite
hydro-électricité dans notre département
d'Indre-et-Loire tous les projets sont
mis en échec systématiquement par les
services de l'État et l'Agence de l'eau
qui utilisent l'arme de destruction
massive et systématique de tous les
anciens équipements hydrauliques des
anciens moulins est-ce que la
réglementation pourrait évoluer à ce
sujet pour permettre enfin aux
propriétaires de produire de
l'hydroélectricité ce qui devient
mission impossible actuellement
deuxième point pensez-vous possible de
faire évoluer le management des
fonctionnaires qui
pour tout projet cherche d'abord les
arguments qui freinent le projet j'ai un
exemple tout simple photovoltaïque
furent six hectares sur une friche
ancien bâtiment militaire de la guerre
405 ou il y a seulement des ronces et
des épines
réponse préalable faites d'abord une
demande de déforestation du terrain
après on verra
c'est l'état d'esprit voilà au lieu de
dire bah présentez votre projet on vous
dira il faut pas faire effectivement par
une autorisation de destruction de la
forêt qui n'existe pas ce ne sont que
des friches c'est un état d'esprit qui
préfère évoluer fille si véritablement
la production d'électricité devient une
priorité nationale merci beaucoup Pierre
Yves Boulou et ensuite Evelyne Renaud
garrabédian que je croyais parti mais
qui est bien là Yves
madame la ministre l'article 18 du
projet de loi institut à rabais sur les
factures
d'énergie au profit des communes
etabli dans les opérations auparavant
excusez-moi dans les environs les
installations ENR par des fournisseurs
d'énergie le montant de ce rabat Rebais
pardon sera déterminé en tenant compte
de la nature et des caractéristiques de
ces installations quelles sont les
critères envisagés
merci Yves Evelyne Renaud garabédian
ministre je voudrais revenir sur un
point que vous avez soulevé tout à
l'heure qui pour moi est très important
qu'il s'agit d'une filière qui est
aujourd'hui sous-développée à gros
potentiel qui est la filière de la
géothermie puisque c'est une filière
aujourd'hui dont on sait que son
potentiel est considérable et qu'elle
participe à la production de chaleur
d'électricité avec des avantages très
particuliers où il possibles de
l'utiliser sur près de 90% du territoire
les infrastructures peuvent fonctionner
toute la journée indépendamment des
conditions climatiques elles ne
détruisent pas le paysage et elle permet
de répondre à 70% des problèmes des
besoins énergétiques des bâtiments je
voulais d'avoir avoir la confirmation
que vous envisagez bien de développer
cette filière de la géothermie merci
merci beaucoup à tous madame la ministre
bon courage parce que le tunnel est long
les questions nombreuses parfois un tout
petit peu redondantes ça va vous
permettre de gagner quelques je pense
quelques temps je vous en prie merci
beaucoup alors sur
mes notes
sur monsieur le sénateur Cabanel la
question de la grille photovoltaïsme
vous savez que nous la ligne sur lequel
on est c'est que l'activité agricole
doit rester significative et c'est un
quart de fou qui est important puisque
on parle de souveraineté énergétique
mais j'ai un collègue qui s'appelle Marc
fenault et qui doit défendre la
souveraineté alimentaire et c'est pas un
petit sujet souveraineté alimentaire
donc je il est clair qu'on va pas
sacrifier un objectif pour un autre oui
il est essentiel de s'assurer un juste
partage
de la valeur et nous sommes pour
un avis cdp9 systématique pour répondre
systématique mais pas nécessairement
conforme
sur la question alors je prends au
passage le sujet de la spéculation sur
le prix du foncé mais je pense que
l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à avoir une une
réelle
enfin un ensemble avec un revenu
agricole et d'ailleurs des aides packs
qui soient compatibles avec les
installations photovoltaïques parce
qu'on a parfois cette question et ça
c'est un problème ce qu'il faut être
cohérent donc on va essayer de bouger
sur ça aussi et
un équilibre pour qui doit revenir
l'agriculteur
monsieur
Guéret alors je suis complètement en
phase avec vous sur la méthode
expérimentale c'est d'ailleurs de ça que
par la circulaire
donc j'aime bien entendu un inquiétude
qui a été exprimée par Madame Estrosi
sessonne mais quand on demande à des
services instructeurs de bosser enfin de
travailler de considérer que c'est une
priorité de travail et j'ai entendu que
ici ça traînait que la ça allait pas etc
on dit au préfet c'est vraiment très
important tenez les délais c'est plutôt
une injonction qui va dans le sens des
collectivités locales quand on demande
de travailler l'adhésion locale
c'est-à-dire de pas se précipiter mais
de s'assurer qu'il y a bien la prise en
compte des élus locaux etc ça va plutôt
dans le bon sens je me permets et
effectivement
quand on renforce parce que vous êtes
plusieurs à avoir demandé la poser la
question les effectifs des services
instructeurs je les dis dans mon propos
je l'ai dit en réponse au président
Longeot je crois que sa figure dans
d'ailleurs en sortie de CNTE on a ajusté
de mémoire l'exposé des motifs pour bien
réintégrer cet élément là et oui nous
allons avoir au total 37 tt
supplémentaires à la DGEC + DREAL ça
sera l'objet du projet loi de finances
que vous allez étudier et ça va être une
augmentation significative a forti par
rapport à des services qui ont apporté
leur livret de chair aux économies de
l'État c'est dernières années est-ce que
c'est suffisant moi ce que je propose
c'est de commencer par recruter les
personnes avoir les bonnes personnes et
faire l'analyse si on tient les 24 mois
ça sera suffisant si effectivement on
s'aperçoit que ça tend et bien on fera
des propositions complémentaires ça
c'est très clair il y a une question qui
est revenue aussi plusieurs fois c'est
sur la question l'accompagnement en
ingénierie pour l'avoir porté beaucoup
quand j'avais la casquette de
l'industrie je fais partie des gens qui
considèrent que
investir un euro dans l'ingénierie pour
en gagner 10 sur les investissements
c'est un bon investissement
on évite parfois des coûts et on
améliore singulièrement les projets donc
ça ça n'engage que moi vous savez qu'on
a mis des crédits d'ingénierie notamment
sur la partie éolien marin vu qu'on me
reprochait on reprocher au MTA d'avoir
des crédits de cabinet conseil en fait
ce sont des gens qui vont faire des
relevés avec des bateaux et donc je n'ai
pas encore l'intention de recruter des
fonctionnaires pour faire cette partie
d'ingénierie mais je pense que c'est
important et on le porte au niveau
étatique pour débrouiller les sujets
aussi pour le compte de futurs porteurs
de projets et sa garantie indépendance
des données vous savez également on a
mis à disposition la NCT pour
accompagner les collectivités locales
alors on peut discuter ça marche ça
marche pas mais c'est un peu l'objectif
quand même et moi je prends le point
mais effectivement je c'est très clair
pour moi que c'est très efficace et on
le voit il y a des territoires qui n'ont
pas la capacité à avoir en permanence
le porteur de le P le le gestionnaire de
projets le directeur ou le chef de
projet
ingénieur 5 ans d'expérience qui peut
débrouiller ces projets rapidement parce
que voilà il y a pas assez de projet il
y a pas assez de moyens il y a pas assez
de possibilités au niveau de la
collectivité locale donc mettre à
disposition ce type d'ingénierie qui t'a
partagé les coûts c'est loin d'être
idéaux et puis il y a effectivement la
question des OPEX et ça on y travaille
sur les contrats par différence mais je
pense que c'est des démarches à creuser
sur donc
Madame Noël sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence
hydraulique je crois que j'ai enfin j'ai
répondu à deux reprises sur
l'interdiction des systèmes de chauffage
sur les terrasses c'est un décret
d'application de la loi climat
résilience que vous avez votée et c'est
une mesure qui est issue de la
convention citoyenne par le climat pour
le climat donc elle a répondu je pense à
une certaine attente sociétale aussi et
je rappelle que notre et j'entends bien
les difficultés mais j'essaye
d'équilibrer vous voyez des enjeux et
notamment l'enjeu du réchauffement
climatique je rappelle juste une chose
moi j'étais à Kinshasa pour préparer la
cop27 il y a deux semaines aujourd'hui
on est sur un scénario à trois degrés de
réchauffement climatique je vous invite
à regarder ce que signifie un scénario
de réchauffement climatique à 3 degrés
je pense que les meilleurs dystopies de
films en mode Mad Max sont très loin de
ce qui nous attend
donc c'est ça qui est en question
aujourd'hui et effectivement la France a
une empreinte carbone qui est modérée au
regard d'autres pays néanmoins là quand
même une empreinte carbone notamment sur
la chaleur et sur les transports et nous
avons contribué depuis notre entrée dans
la révolution industrielle à une partie
pas tout à fait négligeable et
certainement supérieur à ce que pèse
notre population dans la population
mondiale au réchauffement climatique
donc il y a aussi un enjeu de
responsabilité et ce sont ces faits là
qui ne sont opposés et ce sont ces
félins sur lesquels nous interpelle les
jeunes générations donc cette
responsabilité faut quand même la
prendre en charge moi je suis quelqu'un
de très je dirais ancré sur l'effet et
les données chiffrées
de mimétente mais par contre je vais en
passer de d'engagement et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est cette
responsabilité là qui nous engage j'ai
vraiment je vous invite à regarder parce
que c'est à la fois passionnant mais
c'est quand même pas rassurant pour dire
le moins
sur la question
madame Préville de faire une place au
projet participatif
je pense qu'il y a deux choses il y a
effectivement et on l'a vous l'avez dit
plus ou moins fortement sur à différents
endroits
au fond pourquoi ne pas ouvrir ces
projets aux habitants collectivités
locales je pense que c'est une piste de
travail à condition de ne pas être trop
demandeur c'est-à-dire de fixer des
objectifs de monter au café voilà c'est
si on veut mais c'est une façon
effectivement encore une fois ça existe
au Danemark ça existe en Allemagne
pourquoi pas sur la question de comment
on accompagne financièrement des projets
qui en fait la deuxième question en
creux je pense que vous avez des
porteurs de projets aujourd'hui qui sont
prêts à accompagner des collectivités
locales et c'est cet appareil qu'il faut
faire et puis et moi je j'invite aussi à
avoir vraiment une logique de s'engager
avec des porteurs de projets qui sont
sérieux et qui ont l'habitude de faire
des projets parce que une valeur en
termes d'exécution du projet et de
taille critique de certains projets je
dis pas qu'il faut faire des mégas
projets mais certains projets trop
petits ne sont pas donc forcément
toujours les mieux adaptés mais je pense
qu'on peut travailler justement à cet
appareillage et c'est là où le les
préfets peuvent voir aussi un rôle à
jouer et la planification au niveau
régional et au niveau local peuvent
avoir un rôle à jouer en disant
pourquoi ne inviter des porteurs de
projets il y a eu l'idée qui a été
évoquée d'appel à manifestation
d'intérêts qui pourraient être porté par
des collectifs vous voyez ici vous
sénateur dentelle porté par des
collectivités locales rien n'interdit
dans la loi ma connaissance je crois pas
si c'est interdit ça mérite d'être
regardé
mais c'est une très bonne idée
parce que c'est exactement ce que vous
dites c'est de dire au fond les sons des
collectivités locales dire j'ai une zone
qui me paraît appropriée je fais un
appel à manifestation d'intérêt pour me
dire quel est le projet le mieux adapté
et j'essaye ensuite d'avancer pour que
ce projet aboutisse et à la limite je
suis pas forcément de le financer je
peux avoir une petite participation au
capital qui me permet de traîner dans
les conseils et dans les décisions et
d'avoir ma part de voix par rapport à
l'évolution du projet
et je pense que c'est des choses qui
sont très valides
sur alors j'ai évoqué le photovoltaïque
thermique donc vous le mettez en
chauffe-eau solaire c'est la même chose
je crois pas qu'il faille une obligation
parce qu'au fond là encore dans les
bâtiments on a des bâtiments qui
arrivent que ce soit en construction ou
que ce soit en rénovation on a des
situations très différentes en fonction
des localisations des conditions
climatiques des usages des bâtiments etc
mais vous savez que vous avez la
directive eff publicité
énergétique des bâtiments qui arrivent
au niveau européen et qui va comporter
des enjeux y compris de minimum
d'énergie renouvelables sur les
bâtiments donc cette quelque part c'est
une réponse on dit pas quelle
technologie ça peut être la géothermie
ça peut être autre chose mais c'est une
réponse et cette directive va être
extraordinairement dimensionnante aussi
je vous le signale pour ceux qui veulent
s'y plonger benchen n'est pas
complètement finalisée
sur
Madame Berthet c'est ça il y a un enjeu
je sais que vous avez un enjeu sur une
entreprise à papa voilà en particulier
je crois que la mise en relation a été
faite avec mes équipes
et qui a rendez-vous a eu lieu début
août la possibilité sera ouverte sur les
contrats à la long terme grâce au PPA
j'ai eu un peu envie de vous renvoyer la
balle en fait plus vite on veut de la
loi plus vite on peut faire des
c'est un peu
et vous avez raison enfin moi je je
soutiens l'idée que les PPA
contrairement à ce que dit Monsieur gay
mais vous citez un cas particulier de
Total ou justement la puissance publique
à réduit la part du contrat direct porté
c'est en Nouvelle-Calédonie vous savez
que l'État n'est pas compétent mais sur
sur le fond il se trouve que
le conseiller technique qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur la loi énergie
renouvelable arrive de nouvelles
Calédonie et assister le gouvernement
local sur les enjeux énergétiques donc
il pourra vous livrer le détail de
la vision mais effectivement le gros du
contrat que vous évoquez ne sera pas en
PPA mais bien avec Enercal qui est le DF
qui est local pour le dire très vite
très loin de DF et d'ailleurs un accord
cadre a été signé entre le gouvernement
de Nouvelle-Calédonie nerkales et les
les métal
[Musique]
pour décarboner globalement le mix enfin
bon c'est un spécialiste je renvoie vers
lui
je continue et donc pour revenir sur les
PPA oui c'est une piste qui au contraire
des financiarise
la question des contrats d'électricité
on le voit aujourd'hui dans
ce qui ce qui se passe vous avez tous
les matins des cotations sur le prix de
le prix de l'électricité premier
trimestre 2023 en base le prix de
l'électricité premier trimestre en pique
que c'est sur la base de ces prix que
vous offre sont faites que les
énergéticiens ce qu'on appelle ferme
leur position tous les soirs pour éviter
d'être exposé au coup du marché et que
vous vous trouvez de ce fait là avec des
prix qui sont très élevés et qui
incorporent un risque qui est le risque
d'impayé puisque plus les factures
augmentent le risque d'un pays augmente
pour le même volume d'électricité livrée
et qui incor un risque tel qu'il est
évalué par le marché il peut être faux
il peut être vrai de rupture
d'approvisionnement au premier trimestre
2023 en gros est-ce qu'il y aura du
délestage ou pas et ce sont ces éléments
qui font que tes prix s'envolent avoir
des contrats qui sont fondés sur la
réalité de la production et des coûts de
revient long terme et qui permettent de
financer des installations ça une valeur
c'est une valeur pour les collectivités
locales c'est une valeur pour les
entreprises le problème sur les
collectivités locales c'est que vous le
savez que ça va changer la
comptabilisation en norme de dépenses et
donc c'est le point de vigilance que
nous avons puisque
ça peut amener en tout cas c'est un
point de vigilance
de Bercy et totalement légitime par
rapport à notre trajectoire de finance
publique d'éviter de transférer de la de
la charge sur enfin de la de la dette
qui serait dans le temps donc ça c'est
un point je pense qu'il faut y
travailler je l'entends bien mais c'est
là où est le point bloquant et donc vous
lisez bien le texte c'est ouvert aux
acteurs privés et pas aux collectivités
locales
vous avez bien compris
alors on est prêt à étudier l'ouverture
au collectivités locales et je vous dis
le point de vigilance sur lequel on
travaillera voilà mais tel qu'il est
écrit c'est pas ouvert aux collectivités
locales c'est ça que je voulais dire
vous l'avez bien lu dans sa rédaction
initiale ouais
formation des artisans je suis
complètement d'accord on revient sur la
concertation je pense que sur la
concertation
j'avais répondu sur les moyens
complémentaires aussi sur
monsieur Cardon sur l'ifère alors sur
l'hiver qui mieux que l'assemblée
qui représente les collectivités locales
pour réfléchir sur la répartition d'un
impôt qui concerne les collectivités
locales
donc ça c'est le premier la première
ouverture la deuxième ouverture c'est
comme le rappel assez justement madame
la Présidente c'est un sujet de PLF
évidemment mais effectivement c'est un
point qui est valide en tout cas on a eu
des expressions différentes suivant les
niveaux de collectivité locale
je pense que vous avez deux enjeux soit
on augmente la part
globale mais ça peut peser enfin comme
toujours si vous augmentez la part
globale de l'ifère ça réduit le nombre
de projets il y a un peu des
mathématiques soit on
revoit la répartition entre les
différentes niveaux et ça je pense que
ça mérite à un vrai travail de fond
et nous on vous laisse travailler sur ce
sujet là
moyen alors j'ai également la question
sur les moyens renforcés
l'ingénierie d'accompagnement j'ai
répondu sur le rip me enfin R2 IPM
cette disposition elle a évidemment une
portée symbolique déjà c'est de
considérer que les énergies
renouvelables c'est des sujets des
investissements d'intérêt public majeur
je pense qu'on peut s'accorder sur ça
à forti dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique pour notre
indépendance énergétique pour préserver
pouvoir d'achat des Français je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui le prix de sortie des
énergies renouvelables en électricité
que ce soit le photovoltaïque les
l'éolien terrestres c'est très
compétitif par rapport au prix du marché
global
et qu'on est aujourd'hui sur des niveaux
qui seront qui se compareront
favorablement avec le prix d'un nouveau
nucléaire ce qui peut être aussi notre
question
donc ça c'est le premier point mais je
rappelle que en tout état de cause on ne
revient à aucun moment sur les
obligations de protection stricte des
espèces protégées puisque c'est une des
conditions
d'être reconnu comme
intérêt public majeur mais qu'il faut en
il faut retenir d'autres enfin il faut
remplir d'autres conditions pour avoir
une dérogation à l'obligation de
protection stricte des espèces protégées
il faut démontrer l'absence de solution
alternatives de moindre impact que
l'opération de nuit pas au maintien d'un
état de conservation favorable des
populations des espèces concernées dans
leur air de répartition naturelle donc
ces deux conditions qui sont des
conditions au fond sur la biodiversité
elles sont maintenues
elles sont maintenus on dit juste
levons la première condition qui est
considérer que les énergies
renouvelables c'est pas des projets
comme les autres dans la situation
de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et de
tension sur nos approvisionnements
sur le déploiement dans les zinnies
c'est une très bonne question madame la
sénatrice avait il y a une nouvelle
période d'appel d'offres en septembre
pour soutenir une nouvelle vague de
projet cela faisait deux ans qu'on
n'avait pas eu cette cette nouvelle
période d'appel d'offre nous avons saisi
la creux pour modifier l'arrêté
tarifaire photovoltaïque avec des seuils
de guichets tarifaires qui passent de
sang à 50 des primes d'investissement
sur l'autoconsommation qui sont payées
en une fois et pas en 5 versements ce
qui est aussi nature à aider le
financement dans les dans les zones non
interconnectées
il y a une modification des cahiers des
charges appellent pour prendre en compte
l'inflation ça c'est valable pour la
métropole et les zones d'un
interconnectées par ailleurs vous savez
qu'il y a un exercice qui va falloir
faire du PPE spécifique aux zones d'un
interconnectées il a abouti encore mais
vous avez des exercices qui qui sont
compliqués et effectivement on
s'inquiète en métropole des risques de
téléstage ou de blackout mais la Guyane
par exemple c'était
retrouvé avec un tiers de son territoire
en black-out donc voilà ça c'est des
choses qu'il faut adresser ils sont
souvent les parents pauvres de notre
politique énergétique je sais que le
ministre délégué aux outre-mer et très
sensibles pour des raisons assez
évidentes à ces sujets là et je veux
dire ici que je peux voir aussi apporter
une contribution parce qu'il est
absolument
inacceptable qu'un territoire enfin que
la France ne soit pas capable d'apporter
des réponses dans les territoires
d'outre-mer sur ça et pour être honnête
j'attendais enfin je suis assez preneuse
c'est peut-être pas ce projet de loi ça
peut être après mais qui est des groupes
de travail sur ce sujet là au niveau des
deux des deux assemblées parce qu'il
faut aussi que ce soit embarqué par les
élus les élus territoriaux pour pas
qu'on donne le sentiment de vouloir non
plus faire du descendant
sur ces sujets là
[Musique]
moyen humain supplémentaires madame la
sénatrice gakaire j'ai répondu madame la
sédatrice Saint-Pée j'ai également
répondu monsieur nantec j'ai répondu sur
la PPA ouvert aux collectivités locales
au fonctionnement en ingénierie et aux
amis de coloc donc c'est bon madame
Loisier sur les Ener non pilotables
vous savez que l'hydroélectricité il y a
qu'une partie qui est stockable une
grande part est également du fil de
l'eau et la capacité de développement
elle est limitée aujourd'hui alors il y
a des investissements qu'on imagine
faire en tout cas on a une idée du
potentiel notamment sur la CNR ça fait
partie et sur les concessions
hydroélectriques de EDF il y a de la
petite
hydroélectricité mais ça pèse très peu
en réalité dans notre bilan énergétique
globale et puis on on a quand même un
sujet qui est pas complètement
évident
c'est le réchauffement climatique
on a une on a une baisse de capacité de
production aujourd'hui sur le nucléaire
on a une baisse de capacité de
production aujourd'hui sur
l'hydroélectrique du fait des épisodes
de sécheresse
de cette de cet hiver pas nécessairement
sur l'éolien sur l'éolien ça
sera le régime de vent qui nous le qui
nous le diront et je veux indiquer aussi
que en matière d'éolien et d'ailleurs
vous l'avez compris ce projet de loi ne
prononce à aucun moment le mot éolien
terrestre
on a bien vu
aucun moment
donc je le dis parce que comme il est
arrivé que certains commentateurs
fassent procès d'en faire un projet de
loi sur l'éolien terrestre ça m'étonne
un peu c'est clairement un projet sur
les énergies renouvelables qui comprend
évidemment les éoliennes terrestres mais
pas que ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que si je reviens à
un instant sur la question du pilotage
il y a le sujet du stockage qui est pas
qui est un vrai sujet qui sera qui a un
sujet de PPE
il y a un sujet du couplage c'est ce que
font certains projets solaires et éolien
sur des points de raccordement puisqu'en
fait ça augmente
la
l'efficacité des installations donc ça
réduit le problème
de l'altermittence
et au fond
on va avoir mais y compris sur le
nucléaire des très grosses installations
nucléaires peuvent poser des sujets de
pilotage
à 900 mégawatts c'est plus pilotable
4650 mégawatts en réacteur nucléaire
donc ce sujet là on va l'avoir sur tous
les sujets de la PPE et le sujet c'est
comment on ne met pas tous nos œufs dans
le même panier pour effectivement
arriver à voir à répondre à ce sujet
pilotel là où je vous rejoins c'est sur
la géothermie mais
madame la sénatrice Renault garabédian
au fond a également posé la question
c'est une filière que nous souhaitons
développer si une filière qui a qui est
injustement je pense à développer enfin
insuffisamment développé aujourd'hui qui
a beaucoup de
perspectives très gros potentiels
français notamment en
Île-de-France ça tombe bien parce que
c'est la zone la plus dépendante d'un
point de vue énergétique et nous
préparons un plan de développement
actuel avec le BRGM la DGEC et l'ADEME
pour structurer la filière de forage
mais ça pour le coup c'est effectivement
assez pilotable en tout cas ça permet de
réduire assez fortement que ce soit sur
les sujets de chauffage mais également
sur les sujets de climatisation enfin de
refroidissement ce qui va pas être un
petit sujet non plus dans la perspective
du réchauffement climatique et c'était
probablement des solutions qui vont
beaucoup de sens en adaptation
changement climatique
vulnérabilité démantèlement des
éoliennes alors vous m'avez parlé du
démantèlement j'avais parlé des
installations nucléaires ou 40 ans d'âge
moyen mais les sur les éoliennes il y a
une obligation de démantèlement pour le
porteur la recyclabilité aujourd'hui
elle est supérieure à 90%
et nous travaillons sur des innovations
pour aller à 100%
. madame lillmann alors combien de
fonctionnaires j'ai répondu en vous
disant on va commencer par 37 au total
mais pas tous sur les éoliennes parce
qu'il y a un peu sur le climat un peu
sur d'autres sujets énergétiques et une
dizaine Andrea
filière photovoltaïque oui je suis
volontariste je vous je vous partage une
frustration d'avoir travaillé sur cinq
ans sur un projet qui vient de
m'échapper à cause de
lentilles enfin de l'inflation Act
réduction in fashion Act monsieur Biden
ou le porteur de projet nous a appelé
pour nous dire très gentiment vraiment
c'était très bien cet accompagnement
mais vous comprenez bien qu'avec
l'argent que sur la table les États-Unis
vous n'allez pas pouvoir être en
compétition donc ça c'est la réalité
par ailleurs je vais vous rassurer
puisque Thierry Breton a annoncé une
alliance industrielle pour l'énergie
solaire avec la perspective de déployer
30 gigawatts de capacité annuelles d'ici
2025 avec une présence sur toute la
chaîne de valeur et il estime que
l'industrie solaire en Union européenne
pourrait permettre la création de 350
000 emplois il est très précis monsieur
breton et nous avons dans France 2030 un
milliard d'euros avec des appels à
projets ouverts en 2022 sur les
différentes filières énergies
renouvelables donc on compte pas lâcher
l'affaire mais voilà c'est c'est un
sujet sur lequel on doit être mobilisé
au niveau européen et au niveau français
y compris aussi en réglementation j'ai
indiqué et donc ça répond à votre
question plan de R&D et
d'industrialisation ça c'est France 2030
et il y a de l'argent dessus et des
appels à projets ouverts commande
publique vous avez aujourd'hui dans les
cahiers des charges
dans les ccagg cahiers des charges
administratives générales une clause
environnementale obligatoire bien placé
pour le savoir puisque c'est moi qui
l'ai introduit quand j'étais à
l'industrie donc ça c'est un premier
élément pour
faciliter les productions qui sont
responsables environnementalement et
donc les productions européennes et
françaises vous savez qu'il y a un
article dans la commande enfin dans les
directives européennes sur l'achat
publique qui permet aussi d'avoir un
contenu sur les
infrastructures de réseau ça ne couvre
pas
toute l'énergie mais il y a des
éléments sur lesquels on peut
positionner des cahiers des charges qui
prévoit un compte une valeur de prendre
en compte la valeur ajoutée européenne
c'est pas un article facile
d'application on a été remonté le point
au niveau européen et notre cas notre
code de la commande publique comporte
beaucoup d'éléments qui peuvent aider à
structurer ou à faciliter des solutions
qui soient innovantes françaises et
européenne et des solutions
industrielles françaises et européennes
il faut savoir utiliser tous ces
éléments je le dis parce qu'on a
travaillé on avait travaillé à l'époque
avec l'adage de Bercy justement pour
aider les acheteurs il y a un sujet
aussi de formation des acheteurs un
collectivité locale et je le redis la
dash de Bercy se tient la disposition
pour expliquer comment on peut
construire des cahiers des charges qui
sont solides juridiquement et qui donne
et qui permettent de effectivement
choisir le mieux 10 ans c'est souvent la
question le mieux disant tout en étant
parfaitement objective et avec des
critères précis de sélection des
myotisants
on croit que non
monsieur Moga qui n'est pas là
je mets on prend ces questions et je
crois qu'on y a répondu avec
l'intégration la PPA l'agrovoltaïsme et
la question du faire mage madame la
sénatrice Estrosi c'est Sun je vous ai
également répondu monsieur le sénateur
loué je crois que je vous ai répondu sur
la petite hydroélectricité et je le
redis notre
notre circulaire au préfet elle va dans
le sens que vous indiquez c'est de dire
c'est en fait c'est essentiel de trouver
des solutions c'est ça le message il
faut trouver des solutions ces solutions
elles seront d'autant plus faciles à
trouver que vous travaillez sur
l'acceptabilité sociale des projets et
que vous animez une communauté des lieux
locaux que vous apportez avec l'appui de
votre expertise locale de l'aide à la
décision c'est notamment les
cartographies qui sont mentionnés les
cartographies des raccordements les
cartographies des PPR enfin le
cartographie de toutes les contraintes
ou de tous les petits avantages qu'on
peut avoir ça peut aider aussi à bien
positionner les lieux les plus propices
aux énergies renouvelables et donc c'est
dans cet esprit de co-construction qu'on
veut avancer
monsieur le sénateur boulot sur les
critères
du rabais
ce sera défini par décrit je pense que
là encore l'avait vu ça s'est en
construction donc ça fait partie des
sujets sur lesquels on est à votre
écoute et j'ai répondu sur la filière
géothermie donc j'ai terminé
très bien merci merci Madame la Ministre
moi je voudrais vous remercier pour le
temps que vous avez pris comme j'ai dit
vous aviez déjà fait une audition de
deux heures là je crois qu'on a encore
augmenté le plafond mais ce vous l'avez
compris ce projet de loi il interpelle
beaucoup sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets territoriaux donc merci beaucoup
pour le temps que vous nous avez
consacré Jean-François
que vous nous avez consacré pour les
réponses alors effectivement il y a il y
a eu beaucoup de questions
mais je pense que c'est normal mais je
pense que ces questions nous nous allons
les surpasser nous allons pouvoir
dès l'examen de ce texte elle est
surpassée et puis je veux dire dans le
contexte dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est important
effectivement que nous puissions mettre
en vigueur ce texte et ça me paraît
essentiel surtout que je tiens à
remercier l'ensemble des
de mes collègues que ce soit de la
commission des Affaires économique et de
la commission d'aménagement du
territoire pour votre présence pour
votre assiduité et je salue le travail
exceptionnel des deux des deux
rapporteurs qui ont beaucoup additionné
qui ont beaucoup travaillé et qui nous
présenterons l'issue de leurs travaux la
semaine prochaine et je les remercie et
je pense que je vous salue aussi et je
remercie vos services parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a des relations de
proximité il y a eu des échanges qui
sont faits et c'est important que ces
échanges puissent avoir lieu parce que
on a un intérêt commun c'est
effectivement d'avoir à la sortie
du débat le meilleur texte possible
merci et Messieurs madame et monsieur le
Président je me permets de reprendre la
parole c'est pas très habituel mais
juste pour vous dire je crois que vous
l'avez compris on est vraiment dans un
esprit de co-construction pour plusieurs
raisons
la première raison c'est que et on le
voit c'est un sujet où il faut conjuguer
beaucoup de pragmatisme et beaucoup
d'écoute de terrain et donc on voit bien
qu'il y a des curseurs qui sont pas
faciles à trouver vous l'avez entendu
sur le sujet d'acceptabilité
sociale
l'acceptabilité des habitants fait une
proposition c'est une mise de jeu
c'est une mise de jeu sur la
planification
c'est alors c'est sur l'éolien marin
quelque chose qui nous paraît impératif
justement pour bien préparer la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie à
venir d'avoir ce temps de travail sur
la planification par façade maritime et
qu'il faut mener dès maintenant et on en
a beaucoup parlé avec mon collègue Hervé
Berville à la mère qui voit bien en
étant tout le temps sur le terrain et
apporter des élus locaux les tensions
entre les conflits d'usage et également
la perception qu'on les élus locaux de
ces projets donc je pense que c'est ça
fait partie des éléments qui nous
paraissent importants pour pour avancer
sur les autres sujets il y a une grande
ouverture de notre part pour les
instruire de manière très
on va dire pour ceux qui le sont pour
leur mairie de propre avec l'objectif de
faire bouger des curseurs sur les
énergies renouvelables et je pense que
ces travaux ont aussi une vertu c'est
que ils seront
utile pour avoir une bonne préparation
de la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie
et comme je retourne les choses vous
êtes un peu taquine ah non mais vraiment
parce qu'en fait c'est une première
c'est un premier cycle de rodage où on
voit bien que
il y a un certain nombre de
présupposés qu'on a sur les énergies
renouvelables qu'on va pouvoir peut-être
mettre de côté pour rentrer dans un
niveau de granularité plus fin et
qu'ensuite quand on va faire l'exercice
à froid de programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie on va faire ressortir aussi
des choses qui montreront que ça boucle
pas donc c'est là où il faut aller enfin
je le précise ce sont des projets sur
les procédures administratives donc il
s'agit de libérer les énergies sur le
territoire mais je vous rassure en un an
on n'aura pas réalisé
l'objectif de 2050 en termes de
production énergétique donc le débat
qu'on aura en 2023 il sera essentiel et
structurant pour faire cette
programmation énergétique
merci beaucoup j'engage mes collègues de
la commission des affaires économiques à
rester je vous rappelle qu'on a une fin
de voilà on prend trois petites minutes
pour voilà boire et on